Great to be here with you guys. It's so great to be here with you, too. I'm Jason. Hey, what's your name? I'm Sean. And I'm Will. Hey, Will. Hey, I'm just feeling really cozy today.
很高兴能和大家在一起。我也很高兴能和你们在一起。我是杰森。嘿，你叫什么名字？我是肖恩。我是威尔。嘿，威尔。嘿，我今天感觉特别温馨。
Oh, yeah? You want to chat about stuff? I just want to kind of coze up to our listener, you know. Put on some nice soft socks. Nug up. Yeah, just get a nice rap. A wrap, a throw, a Pasmina. yeah and just and just and just like a real like a real cozy like just real cozy like just real cozy welcome
哦，是吗？你想聊聊天吗？我只是想跟我们的听众亲近一下，你知道的。穿上舒服的软袜子。抱一抱。对，裹上一条舒适的毯子。一条毯子，一条披肩，一件克什米尔围巾。对，就是那种，那种，那种真正舒适的感觉，就像一个非常舒适、非常温馨的欢迎仪式。
and if you listen if you listen to the snap crackle pop of the fire you can just bear to hear you can just bear to oh grease up your ear holes everyone here welcome welcome welcome to smartless welcome to smart that's so gross Smart Yes Hi Hi Hi
如果你听，如果你听着壁炉里的噼啪声，你就能隐隐听到，你就能隐隐听到……给你们的耳洞上点油吧，各位，欢迎，欢迎，欢迎来到 SmartLess。欢迎来到 Smart...太恶心了。Smart...是的，嗨，嗨。
How's everybody doing Look at Will's haircut Hey Will You finally figured it out Christ That was some tough sledding there For all of us for a week or so I got a lot of like
大家最近怎么样？看看威尔的发型。嘿，威尔，你终于把它弄好了。天哪，那可真是一段艰难的日子。对我们所有人来说，大概有一周左右的时间。我收到了很多……
I got a lot of really shitty comments You did Someone's got to be honest with you About my hair I know All the people commenting But then like Well, who's responsible for what we had to deal with for a couple of weeks?
我收到了很多非常糟糕的评论。真的吗？总得有人对你实话实说。关于我的头发？我知道。所有人都在评论。但是，等等，谁该为我们过去几周不得不面对的事情负责？
And then who's responsible for this pleasure cut here? Yeah. Same criminal? Was it Eli? No, no, no, no, no. Eli's done a fantastic job. No, I mean, New York, I went and saw my guy, Kevin Woon, who is the best. Oh, I guess the next one's free.
还有，谁该为这个讨喜的发型负责？对啊。同一个罪魁祸首？是伊莱吗？不，不，不，不，不。伊莱做了一项 fantástico 的工作。不，我是说，在纽约，我去找了我的发型师凯文·温（Kevin Woon），他是最棒的。哦，我猜下一次是免费的。
Yeah. Well, I mean, he's never received a mention. He's the best. And what was his name again? It's Kevin Woon. And you were going to spell that for their listener? W-O-O-N. and you'd find him
对。嗯，我是说，他从来没被提起过。他是最棒的。他叫什么名字来着？是凯文·温。你能不能给听众拼一下？W-O-O-N。然后你就能找到他。
and Kevin's with a K You'd find him You ever met a Kevin with just a hard C That'd be pretty funny How would you spell that To make sure no one goes seven So seven No it's Kevin
凯文的“凯”是用 K 开头的。你能找到他。你见过哪个凯文的“凯”是用硬 C 开头的吗？那可挺有意思的。你会怎么拼？为了确保没有人去七号……所以是七号？不，是凯文。
Yeah Or like a QU Yeah Cuevin I am Quaid Wait Will where are you It looks like you're at your grandma's spot I mean do want me to give a shout out
对，或者像 QU 这样的。奎文。我是奎德。等等，威尔，你在哪？你看起来像是在你奶奶家。我是说，你想让我打个招呼吗？
To the hotel it's new Yes it's good It's the Whitby. No, it's Warren Street. Warren Street. Down in Drive-Nex. And you'd find that on Warren Street down there. Yeah.
向这家酒店吗？它是新的。是的，它很好。是惠特比酒店。不，是沃伦街酒店。沃伦街。在翠贝卡。你会在那边的沃伦街找到它。是的。
Yeah. And I got to say, I like those hotels. It's pretty fantastic. Is it? Yeah, it's pretty great. I didn't know what to, because I used to go into the place that we always go to and then...
对。我得说，我喜欢那些酒店。相当棒。是吗？对，相当不错。我不知道该去哪，因为我以前总是去我们常去的那家地方，然后……
You know, Jay, the Farnedale, Firmdale hotels? You know those little boutique hotels? Here comes, Sean, for he'd like a freebie all over the world. Not just that... Wait, I stayed at... Why aren't you at the usual spot, Willie? Because they didn't have what I wanted, because they were full. I see you haven't had your chocolate strawberries over your right shoulder yet.
你知道吗，杰，法恩代尔酒店？Firmdale 酒店？你知道那些精品酒店吗？瞧，肖恩来了，他又想在全世界白嫖了。不仅如此……等等，我住过……威利，你为什么不在老地方？因为他们没有我想要的，因为客满。我看得出你右肩上还没吃巧克力草莓呢。
They're plums. Get your eyes off my plums, man. We haven't really spoken since we did our live show with our buddy John Mare. Which was really fun. That's super fun. It really was out there in L.A. there at the Avalon. Yeah, that was a lot of fun. We're still kind of thinking about maybe doing another.
那是李子。把你的眼睛从我的李子上拿开，老兄。自从我们和我们的好朋友约翰·梅尔一起做完我们的现场演出后，我们其实就没怎么说过话。那真的很有趣。超级有趣。确实如此，就在洛杉矶的阿瓦隆剧院。是的，那真的很有趣。我们其实还在考虑要不要再办一场。
the one later in the year we're not sure well we also keep talking about we know we got a lot of people saying like oh you guys you know you're now you're not doing we we keep talking about doing a tour and it is something that we are uh we have we almost did last year remember we got really close we had dates yeah and then it didn't work out but we have a lot of fun doing it so we we would like to try to if we can figure out a time that we can do it again um plus this other live show jb that you talked about that we may do at the end of the year so you know it is something that we are actively looking to do if anybody cares probably they don't but um it's something that we do also if anybody cares on a granddad is now officially on instagram uh yeah i'm enjoying so
今年晚些时候的那场，我们还不确定。不过我们也不断在讨论，我们知道很多人说，哦，你们，你知道的，现在你们不做了……我们一直在讨论办一次巡演，这确实是我们……我们差一点就在去年办成了，还记得吗？我们离得非常近，连日期都定好了。对，然后没办成。但我们真的很享受这个过程，所以如果我们能找出合适的时间再办一次，我们还是想试一试，嗯……再加上杰比你提过的另一场现场演出，我们可能会在年底举办，所以，你知道的，这确实是我们正在积极筹划的事情，如果有人在乎的话——可能没人会在乎，不过……这也是我们一直在做的事。另外，如果有人在乎的话，爷爷现在正式开通 Instagram 了……对，我很享受……
so what am i supposed to do i'm supposed to put up pictures right this is not like so that the the writing that was twitter i got rid of the twitter but now this is just pictures right so i take like a fun shot of you know me in traffic right i put up stuff like that yeah hey crazy on the 405 today right You just put that up. People love that. Please, please do that. Please just make your Instagram traffic updates. Or shot of a candle burning.
那我该怎么办呢？我是不是该发点照片？这跟以前不一样，以前推特上全是文字，我把推特卸载了，但现在这里只有照片，对吧？所以我拍一张有趣的照片，比如我在堵车时的照片，对吧？我就会发这种内容。对，今天 405 号公路太疯狂了，对吧？你就发这个。人们可喜欢了。求求你了，一定要发这个。求求你，把你的 Instagram 当成路况播报就行了。或者拍一张蜡烛燃烧的照片。
Just relaxing. Do a lot of prey hands, talking about gratitude a lot. What if I can get my dog on a skateboard? Do that? God, that'd be great too. Your views will go skyrocket. Dogs on skateboards.
就显得很放松。做很多双手合十祈祷的手势，经常谈论感恩。如果我能把我的狗弄到滑板上呢？发这个？天哪，那也太棒了。你的浏览量会直线上升。滑板狗。
All right, everybody's been warned. I'll tell you what, I'm going to warn you guys. I'm going to warn you guys about our guests because you guys are both going to be... No, you guys are, I don't, I'm not even looking. You guys are both going to be excited for different reasons, for all the right reasons. This is a big one.
好了，大家都收到警告了。我跟你说，我要警告你们。我要警告你们关于我们今天的嘉宾，因为你们俩都会……不，你们俩都会，我甚至不用看。你们俩都会出于不同的原因而兴奋，而且都是因为完全正确的 原因。这是一个重量级人物。
Really? Yeah. J.B., you're going to be excited on a bunch of different levels. Sean, you're going to be excited on a bunch of different levels, which all meet. I'm excited on a ton of different levels. We get a lot of talented people on here, but I love when we have people on who do lots of different things,
真的吗？是的。杰比，你会在很多不同的层面上感到兴奋。肖恩，你会在很多不同的层面上感到兴奋，而且这些层面最终会交汇。我在无数个不同的层面上都感到兴奋。我们这里来过很多有才华的人，但我最喜欢那些涉猎广泛的嘉宾，
especially when they built up themselves and came from humble beginnings. Our guest today... If this is Elon Musk, I want to apologize for dropping Twitter. He hails from St. Louis, Missouri, so it's not. Our guest is from St. Louis, Missouri, originally. Went to Columbia University. Got a start in showbiz, you know, paid showbiz, working for trauma entertainment out of New York,
尤其是当他们白手起家、出身卑微的时候。我们今天的嘉宾……如果这是埃隆·马斯克，我想为卸载推特向他道歉。他来自密苏里州圣路易斯，所以不是他。我们的嘉宾原本来自密苏里州圣路易斯。就读于哥伦比亚大学。在演艺界起步，你知道的，有偿演艺工作，在纽约为特罗马娱乐（Troma Entertainment）工作，
the home of lots of great... What people would call B-movies, but really, like, low-budget horror films and stuff, really cool stuff. Right, so intentionally kind of close to Trump. but it's not, it's trauma. This is fun. It's fun with the words, Sean.
这里有许多伟大的……人们称之为B级片，但实际上是低成本恐怖片之类的地方，真的很酷的地方。没错，听起来有点像特罗马（Troma）。但不是特罗马，是特罗马（Trauma）。这很有趣。玩文字游戏真有意思，肖恩。
It's fun with the words, yeah. Yeah, yeah. You know, he's written... Lots of films. He's written lots of books. Hang on a second. It's so good. Terrible at this.
玩文字游戏真有意思，对。对，对。你知道，他写过……很多电影。他写过很多书。等一下。太棒了。我真不擅长这个。
His first thing he wrote was Tromio and Juliet in 1997. Oh, shit. He's having fun with the fucking words. He's written so many scripts. It started with the big studios for films like Scooby. do and then Don of the Dead and then Slither which he directed with Nathan
他写的第一部作品是1997年的《特罗马和朱丽叶》（Tromio and Juliet）。哦，操。他在该死的文字上找乐子呢。他写过那么多剧本。从给大制片厂写电影开始，比如《史酷比》（Scooby-Doo），然后是《活死人黎明》（Dawn of the Dead），然后是《撕裂人》（Slither），那是他和内森·
Philly and Elizabeth Banks he went then on went on to do a feature film super Then he went on to do all of the Guardians of the Galaxy's movies and now he is the co-chairman CEO of DC Studios guys is James Gunn Holy shit
菲利安以及伊丽莎白·班克斯共同执导的。接着他去拍了一部剧情长片《超级英雄》（Super）。然后他接着去拍了所有的《银河护卫队》（Guardians of the Galaxy）电影，现在他是 DC 工作室的联合主席兼首席执行官。各位，这就是詹姆斯·古恩！卧槽！
how Bing Bing! What did I tell you? How the paper comes off Hey guys, I tell you. Nice going Will. What did I tell you? What did I tell you? Hey John. How are you? I know, Sean. You do? I do. How do you two know each other?
哇！砰砰！我跟你说什么来着？这纸是怎么撕下来的？嘿，各位，我告诉你。干得好，威尔。我跟你说什么来着？我跟你说什么来着？嘿，约翰。你好吗？我知道，肖恩。是吗？我知道。你们俩怎么认识的？
We had dinner at Chris Pratt's house and then we watched an Alexander Payne movie. That's right. Which one? What was it? Shrinking. No, the one in the winter. It was in the winter and the college. The last one.
我们在克里斯·帕拉特家吃晚饭，然后看了一部亚历山大·佩恩的电影。没错。哪一部？是什么来着？《缩身》（Shrinking）。不，冬天的那部。是在冬天，还有大学。最后一部。
Holdovers. Holdovers. Holdovers. I love that film so much. I know me too. I thought the holdovers was so, so fantastic. Yeah, I love it too. And I know I've met Will a couple times, but I can't.
《留校联盟》（The Holdovers）。《留校联盟》。《留校联盟》。我太喜欢那部电影了。我知道，我也是。我觉得《留校联盟》真的、真的太棒了。是的，我也很喜欢。我知道我见过威尔好几次，但我……
I remember one time it was at a screening somewhere, but it was a long time ago. It was when I was still married to the channel. I was going to say the same thing. We have met a couple times, but it was like 20 years ago. Exactly, yeah. Right. Yeah.
我记得有一次是在某个地方的放映会上，但那是很久以前了。那是我还和频道结婚的时候。我正想这么说。我们确实见过几次面，但那已经是20年前的事了。完全没错，对。没错。是的。
And neither of us remembers it. Didn't leave an imprint with either of us. I remember you standing there. Yeah. I do a lot of that. James, look at all the paintings behind you. Like, you look like you're in a museum almost. Now, hey, now, Sean, who is that?
而且我们俩都不记得了。谁也没给对方留下什么印象。我记得你站在那儿。是的。我经常干这事。詹姆斯，看看你身后的那些画。你看上去简直就像在博物馆里一样。现在，嘿，现在，肖恩，那是谁？
Who is the heavyset fellow there in the black and white? I'm afraid to say, I'm going to give you two guesses. Yeah, yeah. Go ahead. No, I can't. I want to say. I'm going to embarrass myself. I think I might embarrass myself, too.
那个穿黑白衣服、胖乎乎的家伙是谁？我有点不敢说，我给你两次猜的机会。好吧，好吧。说吧。不，我不能。我想说。我怕我会让自己出丑。我觉得我可能也会让自己出丑。
Go ahead. I don't know. I don't know. This is a heavyset black and white photo looks like an old president listener. And I'm going to go with, I'm going to go with Taft. Is it Taft? It is. It's a painting, though.
说吧。我不知道。我不知道。这是一张胖乎乎的黑白照片，看起来像个老总统，听众朋友们。我猜是……我猜是塔夫脱。是塔夫脱吗？是的。不过那是一幅画。
But if you notice, instead of a pocket watch, there's sausage links there. Those are sausage links. I didn't even see that. That's a little bit. It's a very elegant-looking painting, beautiful, and then just kind of, you know, just a smaller part of the painting. There's Sausagelley.
但如果你注意看，口袋怀表的地方居然是一串香肠。那是香肠。我刚才都没看到。这是个小细节。这是一幅看起来非常优雅、美丽的画，然后只是在画的一个较小部分，有香肠链接。
Wait, who did that? I can't remember the artist's name. Yeah, that's great. I love that. James, I'm very excited to meet you. I'm excited to meet you, too. I'm a big fan. I'm a big fan of yours.
等等，那是谁画的？我想不起那个艺术家的名字了。是的，太棒了。我太喜欢了。詹姆斯，很高兴能见到你。我也很高兴见到你。我是你的超级粉丝。我是你的超级粉丝。
I want to know everything about everything that you're doing. Sorry, Will, I know. No, no, no. I do too, and I'm with you. And I'm really, and I mentioned it. in the opening, James, because I think it's so interesting because as a guy who feels like
我想了解你正在做的所有事情的一切。对不起，威尔，我知道。不，不，不。我也一样，我和你感同身受。詹姆斯，我在开场时提到了这一点，因为我觉得这太有趣了，作为一个
I grew up in Toronto, but I really grew up in New York and moved when I was 20, and I remember all the times past, going down 9th Avenue and seeing trauma ads for trauma up on the side of the building. Right.
在多伦多长大，但实际上是在纽约长大、20岁时搬走的家伙，我记得以前无数次走过第九大道，看到建筑侧面贴着特罗马的广告。没错。
And I was also like, what is the deal with these guys at Troma Entertainment? And that's where you got your start. So please just, just tell us a little bit about that experience and what it is and what that was for you. I was still in grad school
当时我还在想，特罗马娱乐公司的这些家伙到底是怎么回事？而那就是你起步的地方。所以请跟我们讲讲这段经历，那是什么样的，对你来说意味着什么。我当时还在读研究生，
and um studying what studying uh writing at columbia and i got a job at troma to write a screenplay for a movie called tromio and juliet for 150 bucks trauma and i'm not saying that as an exaggeration i mean literally 150 bucks uh troma was most known for the toxic avenger films they were like made a lot of money and then they made a you know they started out of it with sort of, you know, T&A movies, like squeeze play, stuff that, you know, I watched on Cinemax as a kid, but that made money in theaters. And then they made a bunch of movies
在……研究什么？在哥伦比亚大学研究写作，我在特罗马找到了一份工作，为一部名为《特罗马和朱丽叶》的电影写剧本，报酬是150美元。特罗马，我不是在夸张，真的是字面意思上的150美元。特罗马最出名的是《毒魔复仇》（Toxic Avenger）系列电影，它们赚了很多钱，然后他们拍了一部……你知道的，他们以青少年成人（T&A）电影起步，比如《Squeeze Play》，那种我小时候在 Cinemax 上看的电影，但那些在影院里很赚钱。然后他们拍了一堆
that made a bunch of movie on video cassette. So they actually made a lot of money in the 70s and 80s, and this was the 90s, so they weren't making as much. But they were never paying anyone for anything. They made money for doing everything for free. I mean, it was traumatic to work for them, you guys. Nice, Jason. Well, Lloyd Kaufman, the head of Trone,
在录像带上赚大钱的电影。所以他们在70和80年代确实赚了很多钱，而这是90年代，所以他们没赚那么多了。但他们从来不付给任何人任何报酬。他们靠做所有不花钱的事赚钱。我的意思是，为他们工作简直是一场灾难（trauma），各位。干得好，杰森。劳埃德·卡夫曼（Lloyd Kaufman），特罗马的负责人，
says that the word trauma means excellence in celluloid in Latin, so I don't know how much... Really? Well, that's what he says. I don't think there's a Latin word for celluloid. But he's kind of like almost like an East Coast, Roger Corman. Is that a fair comparison? Yeah, like a more raw, rougher.
说“特罗马”这个词在拉丁语中是“胶片上的卓越”，所以我不知道有多少……真的吗？嗯，他是这么说的。我不认为拉丁语里有“胶片”这个词。但他有点像是东海岸的罗杰·科尔曼（Roger Corman）。这个比喻公平吗？是的，就像一个更生猛、更粗糙的版本。
I mean, the difference is that Corman just was 100% product, but Lloyd is kind of an artist. It's just that his artistry is... Not kind of, he's an artist. But his artistry is very blood-splattery and sexual and very trashy. But there is a sort of feeling to trauma films that the AIP, Roger Corman's company's films didn't have. Got it.
我的意思是，区别在于科尔曼只是100%在生产产品，而劳埃德有点像个艺术家。只不过他的艺术风格是……不，不是有点，他确实是个艺术家。但他的艺术风格非常血腥、色情而且非常低俗。不过特罗马电影确实有一种 AIP（罗杰·科尔曼的公司）电影所没有的情调。明白了。
But you were able to cut your teeth there. You were given the experience, the opportunity to write a script, to write a screenplay. You didn't even go into, is it true you were applying for a job just to work there? They asked you to write it? Sort of I mean I went in to meet with him And then he had By the end of that meeting
但你确实在那里崭露头角了。你获得了经验，获得了撰写剧本、编写剧本的机会。你甚至没有去……这是真的吗？你当时申请工作只是为了在那里上班？是他们让你写的？算是吧。我是去见他的。然后在会面结束时，
I think he asked me to write the screenplay I I I was doing like These sort of monologues It was these monologue Things Downtown New York
我想他让我写剧本。我当时在做……那种独白。那是纽约市中心的独白表演。
And so he kind of knew who I was from that Right Okay Yeah the thing is is that Troma and I just was able to learn About every single Fasset of filmmaking So yeah I wrote the screenplay
所以他通过那些大概知道我是谁了，对吧？好吧。对，问题是，特罗马让我能够学到电影制作的每一个环节。所以，是的，我写了剧本，
but I ended up my credits, I think, are executive producer but then also associate director because I basically ended up, you know, directing portions of the film. That's a sitcom title. It is. One of my first jobs was to choreograph a sex scene between two women. So that was sort of my first, yeah, it was horrible. It's a different job title nowadays.
但最终我的署名，我想是执行制片人，但也是副导演，因为我基本上最终……你知道的，导演了电影的一部分。这听起来像个情景喜剧的片名。确实是的。我的第一份工作之一就是指导两个女人之间的性爱场面。所以这算是我的第一份……是的，太可怕了。现在这个职位名称可不一样了。
I think I speak for Sean when I say, gross. That's the quote from this episode. So then you learned a lot of stuff about the nuts and the bolts of making a film because you were on set a lot for the thing that you wrote? Well, I was on set every single day. I directed the actors. Nobody talked to the actors but me. Gotcha.
我想我可以代表肖恩说：太恶心了。这就是本集的金句。所以你学到了很多关于拍电影的具体细节，因为你为你写的东西在片场呆了很长时间？嗯，我每天都在片场。我指导演员。除了我，没人跟演员说话。明白了。
It was like I just learned and I would come home every day from work with the girl I was living in at the time. And I think I've found my home. It was like I was alive. What felt so great? about it? Was it just like the fun of making fake life? Yeah, I think it just, I was good at it. Yeah. I really was good at it. And I, I
就像我学到了东西，我每天下班回家时，都跟我当时住在一起的女孩说。我想我找到归宿了。那种感觉就像我活过来了。是什么让你感觉那么棒？仅仅是制作虚构生命的乐趣吗？是的，我觉得我就是擅长这个。是的。我真的很擅长。而且，
mean, it wasn't like I had no experience making films. I started making films when I was very young, just out of fun. But I was just one of these artistic kids that did everything. I made films, I took photographs. I played in rock bands. I did comic strips. But I understood filmmaking pretty
并不是说我没有拍电影的经验。我从很小的时候就开始拍电影了，纯粹是为了好玩。但我就是那种什么都做的文艺小青年。我拍电影，我拍照片。我在摇滚乐队里演奏。我画连环画。但我对电影制作理解得相当
well. Yeah, you were making films as young as eight with your brother. Is that true? Yeah, I think about 11, I started making movies, and it was like I had seen Friday the 13th and I'm like oh we can all do this and and I was tearing apart my brother Sean who's an actor now um you know with fake blood and but like but look at all of that and in the years from then until now I mean look at where you are and what you're doing like what is it tell me you're not jaded and it's not lost on you like how freaking awesome it is that you're
好。是的，你甚至在八岁左右就和你的兄弟一起拍电影了。真的吗？是的，大概11岁时我开始拍电影，当时我看了《十三号星期五》，心想：哦，我们所有人都能拍这个。我当时在用假血“虐待”我弟弟肖恩（他现在是个演员）……但看看这一切，从那时到现在的这些年里，看看你现在身处何地，在做着什么——告诉我你没有变得冷漠，你没有忘记，做着你八岁或十岁时就热爱的事情，是多么酷的一件事？你觉得是因为这份热情才让你走到了今天？还是说，这其中包含着巨大的运气，天时地利人和？我敢肯定这二者兼有。我觉得这是多种因素结合的结果。这是运气的结合。运气绝对在其中发挥了作用。我想部分原因在于，我不知怎么地能够把世界上其他人怎么想的声音屏蔽掉，只从一个创造性的地方出发去行动。
doing exactly what you're passionate about when you were what eight 10 and and do you think it was because of that passion that you're where you're at now? Or was it just, was it, was there a moment of great luck, right place, right time? I'm sure a combination of a lot of it. I think it is a combination of a number of things. It's a combination of luck. Luck is definitely plays a hand in it. I think a part of it is that I still, I somehow am able to shut out the world about what
哇。所以我不需要为了去迎合……你知道的，那样的事情可以在之后再来。但与此同时，我有一种右脑思维的心态，所以我能够思考事物是如何融入某种模式的。为了商业可行性等你需要勾选的方框。我是说，是的，拼图的那一部分对我来说也是其中一部分。
the world thinks and just act from a creative place. Wow. So I don't have to do what I'm doing to like, you know, please. like that can come in after. Yet at the same time, I have a right brain mentality, so I'm sort of able to think how things fit into a pattern. The boxes you need to check for the commercial viability of it, etc. I mean, yeah, the puzzle making part of it is a part of it for me.
所以我想，是的，我觉得我拥有了热情、创造力与超然之间的正确结合。而这正是你现在运营工作室、处理 DC 业务时所需要的，你不仅必须是创意核心，还必须监督你招募到手下的其他创意人员，确保有时也能以某种企业议程来统筹事物。是的，虽然我有一个合作伙伴彼得·萨夫兰（Peter Safran），他负责处理所有我不想处理的事情，所以他去参加所有的公司会议……干洗，你
So I think, yeah, I think I have the right mix of being passion, creativity, but also detachment. Which you need now running the studio, the DC element, you've got to not only be the creative element but you also have to oversee other creatives you bring in underneath it and make sure that you're you're marshalling things in more of sort of a corporate agenda at times as well yes yeah although i have a partner peter saffron who takes care of everything that i don't want to have to take care of so he goes to all the corporate meetings dry cleaning you you built in you built in a bad guy he picks up my dry cleaning yeah right you built in a bad guy so like you so somebody comes he goes like hey we want to do this you're like i'd love to but peter says we can't
培养了一个“恶人”。他帮我取干洗衣服。对，你培养了一个“恶人”。所以当有人来找你说：“嘿，我们想这么做。”你就会说：“我很想，但彼得说我们不行。”
I hate to say it. I'm still the bad guy. But he takes care of all the, you know, sort of practical stuff in the studio. He knows all about the money and all. I don't know what's going on with that. Right, right. I really am here mostly to try to, you know,
我很不想承认。我仍然是那个恶人。但他负责工作室里所有……你知道的，比较实际的事情。他精通金钱之类的一切。我根本不知道那方面是怎么运作的。对，对。我来这里真的主要是为了尝试……你知道的，创作出好的故事。你知道的，我们的核心承诺之一就是对故事创作本身的承诺。这意味着编剧们会被……你知道的，提升到一个他们应有的地位。我认为他们在好莱坞的地位在某种程度上被削弱了，尤其是在电影制作中，而在电视领域也是如此。我们要确保永远不会将一个我认为尚未完成且不够伟大的剧本投入制作。
create creative, you know, stories that are good. And, you know, one of our main commitments is to the writing of the story. So that means that the writers are, you know, lifted up in, you know, a place where they've been, I think, just sort of their places, is diminished in Hollywood, especially in filmmaking, that in television,
你提到了一个非常棒的观点。我觉得有太多时候……编剧们，尤其是在电影领域，被视为理所当然。人们觉得：我们要拍这部电影，随便找个人写个剧本，然后我们就开拍。这就好像是，不，不，不。你跳过了最大的一步，那就是你必须有扎实的素材。否则你在干什么？人们却总是把这一步跳过去。詹姆斯，有时候这难道不与你的理念产生冲突吗？特别是当你负责 DC 的那些大型支柱大片时，你必须在地上插上一面写着上映日期的旗子。然后有时候那个剧本还没写好，但为了赶上电影制作、所有的特效以及那个上映日期，它必须在某个特定时间之前写完。这难道不有时会与你说的“在剧本完善之前我们什么都不做”的原则相冲突吗？确实会，但我会改期。我才不管呢……我的意思是，如果非得那样的话，我懂我的意思。一般来说，我们都是根据……你知道的，现成的剧本开拍的。《超人》完成了，大家都很喜欢，我们就拍了《超人》；《超级少女》是由这位出色的……你知道的，编剧安娜·诺盖拉（Ana Nogueira）写的，那真的很好，所以我们绿灯放行了；《泥面人》（Clayface）带着麦克·弗拉纳根（Mike Flanagan）写的一个很棒的剧本找到了我们，于是我们绿灯放行了；《蝙蝠侠2》里，马特·里夫斯（Matt Reeves）你知道的，把上映日期推迟了几次，
and to be able to make sure we never go into production on a script that I don't think is finished and great. That's a great point that you bring up. I feel like there's so much... The writers, especially in film, have been sort of taken for granted in the sense, like, we're going to make this movie. We'll get somebody to just write it,
但这是……你知道的，我们推迟日期是因为马特还没准备好剧本，我们需要给他时间按照他想要的方式完成剧本。太棒了。没错，这真的很棒。我经历过……我的意思是，到现在为止我参与过很多大制作电影，我发现问题总是
and then we're going to make this movie. It's like, no, no, no. You're skipping the biggest step, which is you need the material needs to be. be there. Otherwise, what are you doing? And people just kind of skip over it. Isn't that at odds sometimes, James, when, especially in the big tent pole stuff that you guys do there at DC, you have to like put your flag down on the ground with a date. And then sometimes that script is not yet written, but it has to be written by a certain time in order to make the
出在那些剧本上，你知道的，他们会说：“好吧，我们有了第一幕，真的很棒。把制作日期定在六个月后吧。”然后他们就开拍了。但他们还没有最后一幕。他们是在拍摄过程中边拍边写的。而剧本根本不是这么运作的。
film, all the effects and all that stuff and hit that release date. Isn't that sometimes at odds with you saying we're not doing anything until the script's right it is but i'll change the date i don't you know i mean if that has to happen got i mean i just generally you know we've been just running off of uh you know screenplays so superman got finished people liked it we made superman supergirl uh was written by this wonderful uh writer uh an igora and then that was really good and so we greenlit that you know playface came into us uh by mag flanagan he wrote a great script and so we greenlit that Batman 2 has had, you know, Matt Reeves, you know, has moved the date a couple times of when it's coming in,
第一幕中的一切，其所作所为都自然地与最后一幕发生的事情相关联。当然，对吧？是的，在这方面你非常有经验。正如杰森所说，你参与过这些宏大的支柱电影，因为你为最大的两个巨头工作过，
but it's, you know, we moved the date because Matt wasn't ready with the script and we need to give him time to finish the script in the way he wants. That's awesome. Right, yeah, that is great. I've been around, I mean, I've been around so many big movies by this time, and I just see that the problems are always
也就是超级英雄 IP 的世界。这里有 DC，还有漫威。你在两者之间来回切换过一段时间。是的。对吧？两者在文化上有什么相似之处吗？
that you have these screenplays that are, you know, they say, okay, well, we have the first act, that's really good. Let's set our production date for six months from now And then they go into production And they don't have the last act And they're writing it during production And that's just not how screenplays work
嗯，DC 工作室的文化是全新的。只有我和彼得。所以我们甚至连三年都还没到。所以这是全新的。至于漫威的文化，我在漫威有很多非常喜欢的东西。首先，凯文和路易，也就是负责人，真的是非常棒的人。凯文·费奇（Kevin Feige）和路易·德·埃斯波西托（Louis D'Esposito）。
Everything in the first act What they're doing is naturally related To what happens in the last act Sure, right Yeah, and you have so much experience in that And as Jason said, working in these big tent pole films Because you've worked on the biggest films For the two biggest players
凯文·费奇和路易·德·埃斯波西托。他们都是很好的人。我真的很喜欢他们，他们也确实关心电影，你知道的。但有时他们会变得……你知道的，我的意思是，就像他们正试图让一切重回正轨一样。他们被迪士尼推出流媒体服务这件事搞得应接不暇，接着又被告知今年需要产出一百万个项目。对。这变得超出了质量控制的极限。所以当你有这样的情况……
is in this sort of the superhero IP world that there is. There's D.C. and there's Marvel. And you have kind of gone back and forth a little bit between the two. Yeah. Right? Is there similarities in terms of the culture between the two?
没错，这就回到了我们刚才在谈的话题，抱歉，肖恩，也就是那种想法：嘿，我们有了一个庞大的流媒体服务，我们需要喂饱这台机器，给我们提供产品。而他们没有选择说“嘿，让我们先把产品做好，然后……”。就是这样。对吧？他们有点本末倒置了。
Well, the culture at D.C. Studios is new. It's me and Peter. So we haven't even been here for three years. So that's new. And the culture at Marvel, there were so many things I loved about being at Marvel. I mean, first of all, Kevin and Lou, the guys who are in charge are just really just great guys. Kevin Feigy for Tracy.
我的意思是，这不怪任何人。他们只是在试图经营一家企业，所以随它去吧。但这就产生了你刚才暗示的质量控制问题。你如何……我们吃晚饭时聊过超人的事情。你当时正沉浸在选角还是别的什么事情中。顺便说一句，肖恩也在。
Kevin Feigy and Lou De Esposito. They're great guys. I really love them, and they really care about the movies, you know. But sometimes they get over, you know, I mean, like they're trying to get things all back on path. They got overwhelmed with, you know, Disney coming out with streaming and then saying we needed a million things this year. Right. And it just became too much to quality control. So when you have something...
或者诸如此类的事情。对。肖恩，你当时试镜了哪个角色？我为超人试镜了。是吗？好样的。他去试镜了。最后在他和科伦斯韦之间二选一。
Right, well, that goes into what we were talking about, sorry, Sean, just the idea that, like, hey, we've got this huge streaming service, we need to feed this machine, give us product, and instead of going like, hey, let us finish the product and then... That's right. Right? They kind of backed it.
对。我穿着动作捕捉服进去了，当时觉得那根本不对。你什么时候……你什么时候穿过动作捕捉？他们捕捉什么？就像你走进冰箱？他们要捕捉那个动作吗？
I mean, it's nobody's fault. They're trying to run a business, and so whatever. But it creates that quality control issue that you alluded to. Yeah. How do you... We were talking about it at dinner when we had dinner about Superman. You were just into casting or something like that. and Sean, by the way.
我可不想让人们错过海滩。看《危险边缘》。当我移动我的蝴蝶结时，太有趣了。永远都那么有趣。现在，听一段来自我们赞助商的广告。好的，回到节目中。不，但是詹姆斯，所以当我听说时——甚至在我们吃晚饭之前——
Or something like that. Yeah. Sean, what part did you read for? I read for Superman. Did you? A way to here. He tested. It was down to him in corn sweat.
当我听说他们——也就是你所在的 DC——要重拍《超人》时，你是如何——这是一个有点笨拙、显而易见的问题——你是如何着手进行一个新的诠释的呢？这是我们前所未见的，有什么不同？你打算……因为我第一次看到时，我想：等等，他们又要拍了，你知道的？
Yeah. I came in a motion capture suit and I just didn't think that was right. When were you ever, when have you ever been in motion? What are they capturing? Like you go into the fridge? They're going to capture that motion?
然后我看到了预告片。我想：哦，天哪，我必须去看那部电影。看起来棒极了。但是，你知道的……嗯，我没……我的意思是，这也是一回事……他们很多年前就带着《超人》来找过我了，你知道的。当时我在想：我不知道。
I don't want people to miss a beach. Watching Jeopardy. It's so interesting when I move my bow. It's forever interesting. And now, a word from our sponsor. All right, back to the show. No, but James, so when I heard about, even before we had dinner,
我很难想象它最终会变成什么样。彼得·萨夫兰，他一直是我的合伙人……他1998年时是我的经纪人，后来成了我的制片合伙人。你知道的，这是他的梦想。拍一部《超人》电影一直是他的梦想。所以他总是提起这件事，总是缠着我，你知道的，就这件事软磨硬泡我。
when I heard about they, meaning you in D.C., we're doing Superman again, how do you, this is like clunky, obvious question, but how do you approach a new take on it that we haven't seen, And what is going to be different? And what do you... Because when I first read it, I was like, wait, they're doing it again, you know?
最终，你知道的，我只是在脑海里不断琢磨这件事。这就好像是一个我试图解开的数学题。比如，超人到底该怎么拍才能行得通？然后我终于开始看到了它的轮廓。这是几件事情共同作用的结果，第一，我重读了一本我很喜欢的旧漫画书，叫《全明星超人》（All-Star Superman）。它有一种白银时代的感觉，却又扎根于经典的科幻风格，老派的科幻，但同样是非常接地气的角色，围绕着超人这个角色有很深的道德议题。我看到了那可能不是我能讲的故事，但我可以直接借鉴那本漫画书的风格。格兰特·莫里森（Grant Morrison）、弗兰克·奎特利（Frank Quitely）和杰米·格兰特（Jamie Grant）创作了那本书。所以我觉得那是其中的一部分，
And then I see the trailer. I'm like, oh, my God, I have to see that movie. It looks amazing. But, you know... Well, I didn't. I mean, again, it was a thing of... They came to me with Superman, you know, many years ago. And I was like, I don't know.
然后就是把各种想法揉合在一起，融入其中。接着我养了这只蠢狗奥祖（Ozu），它把我的东西全毁了。我想：哦，天哪，如果这只狗有超能力，我的生活和我的房子不就被毁了吗。等一下，你在电影里看到的狗的名字，就是你现实中的狗吗？不，我的狗叫奥祖。是的。但它就是小氪（Krypto）三维建模的原型。小氪是电影里那只狗的名字？小氪是那只狗的名字。对，它是漫画里超人的超级狗。它以前从未出现在电影里。
I just had a hard time imagining what it was going to be. And Peter Safran, who's been my partner... He was started out as my manager in 1998 and has, you know, since become my producing partner. You know, it's his dream. It was his dream to make a Superman movie, always. And so he was always bringing it up, always just bullying with me, you know, bullying me about it.
它能出现在电影里真是太棒了。你刚才提到了，肖恩也提到了，你知道的，超人，每个人都对这个角色很熟悉。而且有这样一种现象——也许你能对此做一些解释——人们不断地回归这些角色，尤其是那些他们喜欢的超级英雄角色、漫画书角色，出于某种原因，它们持续产生共鸣。
And eventually, you know, I just kind of kept playing it in my head. It was like a math problem I'm trying to solve. Like, how could Superman work? And then I finally started to see it. And it was the culmination, of a couple of things, number one, that I read, I reread an old comic book I really like a lot called All-Star Superman. And it had a sort of silver age, yet grounded classically sort of science,
我知道关于这部新的《超人》，我读到过你试图……你知道的，创作一部展现一个更美好、更善良的世界愿景的作品，对吧？那里有更多善良的事情发生，尤其是当我们生活在一个复杂的时代时。我就直说了，将这种信息融入所有这些电影中对你来说很重要吗？
old school science fiction, but again, really grounded characters and deep moral issues around the character of Superman. And I saw how that wouldn't be the story that I could tell, but I could just rip off the way that comic book was. Grant Morrison and Frank quietly and Jamie Grant did that book. So I think that was part of it
这并不总是我做某事时的出发点，但在这部电影里确实是。当我们在开拍前坐下来吃饭时，我对演员们说，这是一部关于善良的电影。它不是关于一个善良的世界。《超人》中的世界在很多方面和我们的世界一样残酷，但超人是善良的。
and then just kind of just playing around with ideas and coming into it. And then I got this stupid dog Ozu who was destroying all my stuff and I thought, oh my God, what if this dog had superpowers my life would be destroyed my house. Wait a second, your real dog
而这才是他真正的超能力。而且，你知道的，他不会回避这一点，对于他很善良这件事，并没有带有一种讽刺的扭捏，他就是直截了当地善良，这不是个笑话，我们不是在取笑他，你知道的，他是一个叛逆者，而他的……你知道的，他的叛逆表现为纯粹的善良、美好和爱。
is the name of the dog that's in the film? No, my dog's name is Ozu. Yeah. But he is what crypto is 3D modeled based upon. Crypto's the name of the dog in the film? Crypto's the name of the dog. Yeah, he's Superman's Superdog from the comics. He's never been in the movies.
我很喜欢这个信息。我觉得这真的很……我记得几年前我对我的一个儿子说，他在说话时说——这有点私密，但他当时说：“爸爸，我觉得我真的很敏感。”我说：“那是你在这个世界上的超能力。”
That's so great that he's in there. You talked about it, and Sean, you mentioned, like, you know, Superman, everybody's familiar with that character, and there is something about, and maybe you can sort of shed some light on this, people keep returning to these characters specifically these superhero characters comic book characters that they like and for some reason they continue to resonate
“而这个世界会试图把它从你身上夺走。”“别让他们把它夺走。去顺应它。那是你真正拥有的、真正的超能力。”天哪，这是个很棒的父亲说的话。真的很棒。太美妙了。嗯，这是真的。我觉得这真的是真的。
and I know with this new Superman I read that you were trying to you know do something that sort of painted a nicer sort of kinder vision of the world right where there was more good happening and especially where we were living in complicated times I'll just say that is that important for you to get that kind of message
而且我觉得我们常常忽视这一点。我认为，在传统观念中，它更多的是关于：你知道的，如果有人攻击你，你就更重地打回去，不要对任何人逆来顺受，往他们鼻子上打一拳之类的那种。这就好像是——你知道，看看这把我们带到了哪里。是的，你知道的，完全正确。是的，所以我很喜欢这个想法——在它的核心，你拥有一个超级英雄——虽然不想在超人身上花太多时间，我知道，但——仅仅是——这对你来说很重要。哦，是的，绝对的。这非常重要，而且我认为这真的是——我想这就是为什么我曾经与这个角色纠缠不清，因为我以前写过
through in all of these films? That's not always where I'm at with something, but with this film I was. I said to the cast when we sat down for our meal before we started, that this is a movie about goodness. And it isn't about a world that's kind. The world in Superman is as unkind as our world in many ways, but Superman is kind.
这些角色，在某些方面它们恰恰与此相反。那些角色……你知道的，比如《银河护卫队》里的火箭浣熊（Rocket Raccoon）、星爵（Star Lord）以及和平使者（Peacemaker），他们都是些言语夸张、愤怒的个人，你知道的，在他们内心深处，他们是善良的，但要剥开外壳抵达真正的自我需要下一番功夫。没错。而这正是这些故事所讲述的。
And that's his real superpower. And that's, you know, the fact that he does, doesn't balk from that, that there isn't an ironic flip on the fact that he's kind, that he's just straight up kind, it's not a joke, we're not making fun of him, and that's, you know, he is a rebel and his, you know, his rebelliousness, you know, manifests itself in just kindness and goodness and love.
我想这也是我直到那个阶段的人生写照，因为我曾经就是那样的人。但我认为，这在我的不同人生阶段来到了我身边，在这个阶段，我更能接受顺其自然……你知道的，太逗了。难道不滑稽吗？是的，继续。
I love that message. I think that that's really, I remember saying to one of my sons, a few years ago, I said, he was talking, and he said, it's quite personal, but he said, you know, Dad, I feel like I'm really sensitive. And I said, that is your superpower in this world. Yeah. And the world will try to take that away from you.
抱歉。聊聊 Instagram 吧。不，我刚才在看 Instagram。你看到了有趣的东西。我们正在进行真正的对话。聊聊你在 Instagram 上看到的东西吧。不，因为那太离谱了。所以你继续讲你的。
And don't let them take that away. Lean into that. That is the true, true superpower that you have. Man, that's great dad stuff to say. That's really great. That's beautiful. Well, it's true. I think it's really true.
你继续讲你的。因为我很想回过头来探讨一下右下角的那个按钮到底是什么。不过等我们到了那一步……我正想说。不，我正想说。对，请说。在我的 Instagram 信息流里……我太想看你们俩大吵一架了。在我的 Instagram 信息流里，当然，是我的算法。
And I think that that gets lost on us. I think that there was, you know, that traditionally it was much more about, you know, if somebody comes out, you hit them back harder and don't take no shit from nobody and punch them in the nose and all that kind of stuff and it's like you know look where that gets us yeah you know exactly yeah and i think so i love the idea that you that you at the center of it you have a superhero who uh not to spend too much time on superman i know but but but just that that that was important to you oh yeah absolutely it was very important and i think it's really you know i think that was why i struggled with the character because i've normally written
但前几天弹出一个视频，是关于你在电影里是否应该给超人穿紧身裤的讨论。哦，不。不，是短裤。你有短裤什么的。短裤。对，就是那个外穿内裤。我觉得整个关于……的讨论简直太搞笑了。
these characters are that are sort of the opposite of that in some ways characters um like you know, Rocket Raccoon, from those movies and Star Lord and Peacemaker, who are these blustery, angry individuals who, you know, at their heart, they're good, but it takes this work to get to who they are. Right. And that's what the stories are about.
他该不该穿内裤？他不该穿内裤？哦，你根本不明白。带我们了解一下。我们有时间。我敢肯定，有人会为了超人到底该不该穿内裤这场争执而杀人。
And I think that's what my life was about up until that point, because I was like that. But I think that this comes to me at a certain different point in my life where I am more okay with just being, You know, it's so funny. Isn't that funny? Yeah, go ahead.
所以我直到加入这部电影并开始尝试设计超人制服之前，都不知道还有这么一场讨论。事实是，超人在漫画里一直都穿外穿内裤。这有意义吗？我的意思是，算有吧。它们的出现是因为当杰瑞·西格尔（Jerry Siegel）和乔·舒斯特（Joe Schuster）最初创造这个角色时，
I'm sorry. Talk about Instagram. No, I was on Instagram. You saw something fun. We're having a real conversation. Talk about the thing you saw on Instagram. No, because it is so left. So keep going with yours.
他就像是一个摔跤手或马戏团大力士。所以他在服装外面穿了这些内裤。但随后扎克·施奈德（Zach Snyder）来了，那是黑暗、更……你知道的，更冷酷、更帅版本的超人。没错。他没有穿内裤。他去掉了外穿内裤。所以当扎克去掉了内裤时，
Keep going with you. Because I'd love to double back just on what the button is in the bottom right hand corner. But when we get there, I was going to say. No, I was going to say. Yeah, go ahead. In my Instagram feed... I want you to fight so bad. In my Instagram feed, of course, is my algorithm.
有大量的粉丝感到愤怒。当然。有些人把所有的……你知道的，我们以为我们的世界是按共和党人和民主党人划分的，每个人都在为那些事情争吵。为了内裤。那是因为你不知道——有一整个群体的人甚至不知道唐纳德·特朗普是谁，或者几乎不知道。他们唯一关心的就是超人到底穿不穿内裤。
But a video came up the other day about you in the movie about whether you should put tights on Superman or not. Oh, no. No, it's the shorts. You have the shorts or whatever it is. The shorts. Yeah, it's the trunks. I thought it was hilarious that there was this whole conversation about...
我能告诉你吗？这些年来我对此略有体会，当时我……我为乐高电影和乐高蝙蝠侠电影里的乐高蝙蝠侠配音。哦，这是个很棒的黑暗角色。他真的是个很棒的角色。抱歉。内部笑话，詹姆斯。请多担待。我懂。我试着在剧院后排模仿乐高蝙蝠侠。
Should he have trunks? Should he not have trunks? Oh, you don't even understand. Walk us through. We got time. Somebody, I am sure, that somebody would kill somebody else over the fight over whether Superman should have trunks or not.
他该穿内裤吗？不该穿吗？哦，你根本不懂。给我们讲讲吧。我们有的是时间。我敢肯定，有人会为了超人到底该不该穿内裤这场争论而大打出手。
So I wasn't aware of this conversation until I came onto the movie and I started trying to design the Superman suit. And the truth is Superman always had trunks in the comics. Do they make sense? I mean, sort of. They existed because when Jerry Siegel and Joe Schuster first created the character,
所以在加入这部电影并开始尝试设计超人战衣之前，我并不知道有这个讨论。事实是，超人在漫画里一直都穿内裤。这合理吗？我的意思是，算合理吧。它们的出现是因为杰里·西格尔和乔·舒斯特最初创造这个角色时，
he was like a wrestling guy or a circus strong man. And so he has these trunks on over his costume. And but then Zach Snyder came in, and that was like the dark, more, you know, mean, cool version of Superman. Right. And he didn't have trunk. He took away the trunks. And so when Zach took away the trunks,
他就像一个摔跤手或者马戏团大力士。所以他的战衣外面套了内裤。后来扎克·施奈德来了，那是个黑暗、更冷酷、更酷的超人版本。对吧。而且他没有穿内裤。他去掉了内裤。所以当扎克去掉了内裤，
there were tons of fans that were outraged. Sure. There are people that spend all the, you know, we think our world is divided in terms of Republicans and Democrats, and then everybody's fighting about that stuff. About trunks. That's because you don't, there are whole factions of people that don't even know, barely know who Donald Trump is. And all they care about is whether Superman has trunks or something.
有大量的粉丝感到愤怒。当然。有些人花所有的……你知道的，我们以为我们的世界是按共和党人和民主党人划分的，每个人都在为那些事情争吵。为了内裤。那是因为你不……有一整派人甚至不知道，几乎不知道唐纳德·特朗普是谁。他们关心的只是超人穿不穿内裤之类的事。
Can I tell you, I had a small taste of that over the years when I, when I, I did the voice for Lego Batman in the Lego movies and the Lego Batman movies and the Lego Batman. Oh, this is a lot of dark figure. He's a really great character. Sorry. Inside joke, James. Just bear with us. I get it. I tried to do Lego Batman in the back of the theater as the dude.
我能告诉你吗，这些年来我对此略有体会，当时我为《乐高大电影》、《乐高蝙蝠侠大电影》以及《乐高蝙蝠侠》里的乐高蝙蝠侠配音。哦，这是一个很黑暗的人物。他真的是个很棒的角色。抱歉。内部笑话，詹姆斯。请多包涵。我懂。我试着在影院后排模仿乐高蝙蝠侠的声音。
But I remember I got dragged in over the last sort of 10, whatever it's been, since I first did it, 10 years. And all these, and I get, speaking of Instagram, tagged in these arguments about who's the best Batman. And I'm telling you, it's twice a week, huge, and thousands of opinions and things about things and specific things. I'm like, it means something. Yeah, it means something to people.
但我记得在过去的差不多10年里——不管具体是多少年，自从我第一次拍那部戏开始——我一直被卷进去。说到Instagram，我经常被@进那些关于“谁才是最佳蝙蝠侠”的争论里。我跟你说，一周能有两次，规模巨大，里面有成千上万的各种观点和特定细节。我觉得，这说明了一些问题。是的，这对人们来说意义重大。
It means something. It's everything. Yeah, it is. It's crazy. It's like a religion to some people. Yeah. I mean, that, it may not be the healthiest thing for a person. So, I mean, but it's an issue.
这很有意义。这就是一切。没错，确实如此。太疯狂了。对有些人来说，这简直就像一种宗教。是的。我是说，这可能对一个人的身心健康不太好。所以，我是说，但这确实是个问题。
And so, yeah, people keep arguing about the trunks. And then I came out and our Superman has trunks because, and I really couldn't decide, but David Corrin Sweat was like, you know what? This is a guy who can fly around. David Corrin Sweat plays Superman. He can fly around. He shoots beams out of his eyes. He can do all these scary things.
所以，是的，大家一直在争论紧身短裤的事。后来我们公布了新超人的造型，我们的超人是穿紧身短裤的，因为——其实我一开始也很纠结，但大卫·科伦斯韦就说：“你知道吗？这是一个能在天上飞的家伙。大卫·科伦斯韦饰演超人。他能在天上飞，眼睛能发射激光，他能做出所有这些可怕的事情。”
He's an alien. from outer space, but he really wants kids to like him. So he's going to wear this, you know, sort of garish colorful costume. Kids love short shorts. They aren't that short. They're trunks. They're trunks. But isn't it born from kind of a practical purpose to
他是个来自外太空的外星人，但他真的希望孩子们喜欢他。所以他要穿这种，你知道的，有点花哨鲜艳的服装。孩子们喜欢超短裤。其实也没那么短。那是紧身短裤。那是紧身短裤。但它不也是出于某种实用目的才诞生的吗？
kind of keep things somewhat discreet on our superhero? Because he's wearing some clingy outfits there, one clingy outfit and he needs another layer. Am I wrong? I mean, otherwise we're going to see his religion. Well, I I think that you could design the pants
为了在我们的超级英雄身上保持某种程度的低调？因为他穿的是紧身衣，一件紧身衣，他需要再穿一层。我难道说错了吗？不然的话，我们就要看到他的“小秘密”了。好吧，我觉得你可以把裤子设计得
so that they don't outline the ball sack, I think. I don't know, Jay. I don't know. It's difficult. Jamie, you're worried that kids are going to see the super package. Is that what you're talking about? Yeah, the guy's got a real pronounced helmet. You've got an issue. Wow.
不会勾勒出那个部位的轮廓，我觉得。我不知道，杰伊。我不知道。这很难。杰米，你在担心孩子们会看到超级包裹吗？你是这个意思吗？对，这家伙的轮廓真的太明显了。你这倒是个问题。哇。
Guys, these are things you've got to consider in pre-production with the costume fitting, okay? I think it's a smart move. You just attracted an entire new audience. By the way, we're talking about these people in the abstract. These people who have an opinion. Sean says, I see it. The reason it came up in his algorithm,
伙计们，这些都是你们在前期制作的服装试穿中必须考虑的问题，好吗？我觉得这是一个聪明的举动。你们刚吸引了一群全新的观众。顺便说一句，我们刚才是在抽象地谈论这些人。那些有意见的人。肖恩说，我懂。为什么这个话题会出现在他的算法里？
Sean's married to one of them. It's because Sean, and Sean is on their verge. Sean and his husband, Scotty, are like super nerds. And these are the kind of conversations that they have over dinner. Like, I could see that you guys going like, did you hear that? We actually really do. Like in between bites of sloppy, the trunks. The trunks, he's not going to do the trunks.
因为肖恩的妻子就是其中之一。这是因为肖恩，而且肖恩也快成那样了。肖恩和他的丈夫斯科蒂简直就是超级书呆子。他们晚餐时就会聊这种话题。就像，我能想象你们两个会说：“你听说了吗？”我们其实真的会聊。比如在吃肉酱三明治的间隙，聊聊紧身短裤。紧身短裤，他不打算穿紧身短裤。
We do. Sometimes we do about Star Wars, Lord of the Rings and stuff like that. I know, Angel. We do have conversations like that. I know. All right. Thank God you found each other. Can I just say that?
我们会的。有时候我们会聊《星球大战》、《指环王》之类的话题。我知道，安琪儿。我们确实会聊那样的话题。我知道。好吧，谢天谢地你们找到了彼此。我能这么说吗？
I'm just so happy. I know, by the way. I know. Oh, God, who could handle any of this. So... We're going to have dinner tonight, by the way. Sean and... Is that on?
我真是太高兴了。我知道，顺便说一句。我知道。噢，天哪，谁能应付得了这些啊。所以……我们今晚要一起吃晚饭，顺便说一句。肖恩和……那个还在进行吗？
Yeah, it's on. But can I just make this one... Just no cosplay. Can we just say that tonight? Because I don't want one of you showing up a C3B or some shit. Okay. It's going to be boring. So, wait, so James, you had this, like, you know, Scooby-Doon and the sequel and Slyther and
对，在进行。不过我能提个小要求吗……今晚绝对不要Cosplay。我们能先说好吗？因为我可不想你们俩谁穿着C-3PO或者别的什么破玩意儿出现。好吧。那可就无聊了。所以，等等，詹姆斯，你拍过这个，就像，你知道的，《史酷比》还有续集，还有《撕裂人》和
all these things. And then do you feel like Guardians was... How did that come about? And do you feel like that was the thing that kind of launched you to the next level? Oh, I mean, without a doubt. It was like I had actually told my agents that I didn't want to focus on film anymore. Actually, this relates to some of the stuff we were talking about in the beginning. I said, you know, it's like no movies are taken seriously.
所有这些作品。然后你觉得《银河护卫队》是……那是怎么促成的？你觉得那是把你推向新高度的作品吗？哦，我是说，毫无疑问。当时我甚至跟我的经纪人说过，我不想再专注于电影了。其实这跟我一开始谈的一些事情有关。我说，你知道的，现在好像没有多少电影会被认真对待。
They aren't a part of the cultural conversation unless it's like a Hulk movie or a Marvel movie or something. I'm making these lower budget films. Like, they just aren't resonating. You know, I had just signed a deal to do another TV pilot, which I'd always do. done. And I was like, you know, it seems like the really creative space for writers these days and even directors is in television. That's where you kind of do what you want. Television is taken the place of the art film in a lot of ways. Yeah, for sure. So I said, I am going to just focus on television. I had also just done a video game, which I had a lot of fun doing. I'm going to
它们根本构不成文化对话的一部分，除非是像《绿巨人》或者漫威电影那种。我拍的这些低预算电影，根本引发不了共鸣。你知道的，我刚签了一份协议要去拍另一个电视剧试播集，我以前经常这么干。当时我想，你知道的，如今对编剧甚至导演来说，真正充满创意的空间是在电视领域。那才是你能随心所欲的地方。在很多方面，电视剧已经取代了艺术电影的位置。是的，绝对是这样。所以我说，我打算只专注于电视。我刚做完一款电子游戏，那过程我玩得很开心。我打算
focus on creating TV and video games. And it was then that Marvel called and said, we want you to come in and meet about this thing. And I was like, oh, I have to drive down. They were in Manhattan Beach at the time. I was in the studio city. I'm like, oh, my God, I got to drive through this terrible traffic. It's such a great L.A. response. You should, by the way, next time you've got a big drive,
专注于创作电视剧和电子游戏。正是在那个时候，漫威打来电话说，我们想让你来聊聊这个项目。当时我想，噢，我还得开车过去。他们当时在曼哈顿海滩。我在工作室城。我想，噢，天哪，我得顶着这糟糕的交通状况开车过去。这可真是太典型的洛杉矶式反应了。顺便说一句，你下次要是得开长途车，
next time you got a big drive, go to Jason's Instagram, and he'll give you an update. He's got the Instagram page with the cool traffic site. This is before the Zoom revolution of COVID, right? Yeah. Yeah, this was before Zoom. Exactly. And so I'm like, you know, I'm like, I don't even want to go.
下次要是得开长途车，去看看杰森的Instagram，他会给你实时播报。他的Instagram页面上有个很酷的路况网站。这是在疫情带来Zoom革命之前的事情吧？对。对，这是在Zoom出现之前。没错。所以我当时想，你知道的，我甚至都不想去。
I had met with them before about stuff. So it wasn't like I was getting the call. And so I went in there and I sat down and they told me about Guardians of the Galaxy. And they showed me this pre, you know, art they had done. And it looked to me like Bugs Bunny in the middle of the Avengers. And I'm like, I don't know about this stupid. So it's like, I was like, I don't know. But I was driving home in the traffic, so maybe I should be grateful.
我以前跟他们开过会聊别的项目。所以这并不是我一直在等待的电话。于是我去了，坐下来，他们跟我讲了《银河护卫队》的故事。他们给我看了他们做的一些前期概念艺术。在我看来，那就像是复仇者联盟里的兔八哥。我就想，我不知道这蠢东西行不行。所以，我当时想，我不知道。不过我正顶着车流开车回家，也许我该心怀感激。
And now it's worse. Yeah, now it's late afternoon. It's traffic. You've got to go over the floor. Go over there. Yeah, I had to think and listen to music because there was no Instagram where I couldn't Instagram myself doing it. And I was going, you know what? You know, okay, so you're thinking that this raccoon is a drawback.
现在情况更糟了。对，现在是下午晚些时候。堵车。你得开过福尔。去那边。对，我只能一边思考一边听音乐，因为当时还没有Instagram，我没法发Instagram秀自己开车。当时我在想，你知道吗？好吧，所以你觉得这只浣熊是个减分项。
But what if this raccoon is a drawback? But what if this raccoon was real? Like, how would this raccoon come to be? You need to, like, get fucking Bradley Cooper or something like that, you know, to make it happen. So I imagine, like, what if this raccoon was real? And I'm like, oh, my God, this raccoon would be the saddest creature in the universe. He's created in a petri dish, basically. He doesn't, you know, has nothing like him in the universe.
但如果这只浣熊是个减分项又怎样？如果这只浣熊是真实的呢？这只浣熊会是怎么诞生的？你得找个像布莱德利·库珀这样的混蛋来配音，你知道的，才能把它演活。所以我想象，如果这只浣熊是真实的会怎样？然后我想，噢，天哪，这只浣熊将是宇宙中最悲伤的生物。他基本上是在培养皿里创造出来的。他在宇宙中找不到任何同类。
He's completely alone. And so that was sort of the soul of the movie. And then I started thinking how much I loved Star Wars when I was a little kid. And what Star Wars meant to me And I thought that I could create that Not by, you know, mimicking Star Wars But making Star Wars for what would work with kids today So bringing some of the color back
他彻底孤身一人。这就是这部电影的灵魂所在。然后我开始回想自己小时候有多么热爱《星球大战》，《星球大战》对意味着什么。我想我可以创造出那种感觉，不是通过模仿《星球大战》，而是去打造一部适合当今年轻人的《星球大战》。所以我要把一些色彩找回来。
What would, you know, when I walked into the supermarket And saw C-3PO and Chewbacca on the cover of People magazine I was like, oh my God, who are those guys? That's so cool. I knew that I could do that. Yeah, for sure. And you did it. And you like, what a mission accomplished.
当，你知道的，当我走进超市，看到C-3PO和楚巴卡登上《人物》杂志封面的时候，我就想，噢，天哪，这两个家伙是谁？太酷了。我知道我能做到这一点。对，绝对的。你做到了。而且你做到了，简直是使命必达，
times 10. And by the way, Jason, you mentioned the music. I mean, I read that you, James, of course, like a lot of directors, you chose all the music, but not only you choose the music
而且是十倍的成果。顺便说一句，杰森，你刚才提到了音乐。我是说，我读到过，詹姆斯，当然了，和很多导演一样，你选择了所有的音乐，而且不仅仅是你为电影挑选音乐，
for your movies, the soundtracks became like huge hits as albums. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like platinum selling albums. Jay, do you know this? Yeah, I have platinum albums up in my house. It's so weird.
电影的原声带还成为了销量巨大的热门专辑。对，对，对。就像获得白金销量的专辑。杰伊，你知道这事吗？知道，我家里就挂着白金唱片呢。这太诡异了。
Yeah, but yeah, exactly, like introducing a sort of a new level of intrigue and draw to what was typically Marvel sort of like, well, we're going to throw a bunch of, of effects at it and it's going to be really exciting cj but you're putting in this subversive element too
对，不过，没错，这就好比为漫威那种传统的——“好吧，我们要砸一堆特效进去，这一定会非常刺激”的模式——引入了一种全新的悬念和吸引力。杰伊，但你也加入了一种颠覆性的元素，
that exists with the music and with lighting and editorial pace and all that stuff like you really kind of you cooled it up and you hipped it up and it became a whole different lane in marble yeah yeah i think it was like and with the music it was really like i'm creating this space opera with all these characters that people don't know and it's totally wacky and weird so how do you ground this in the coolest way possible. And I'm like, well, 70s A.M. POP would work perfectly over somebody dancing through, you know, an alien graveyard. So cool. Can I just tell you, just apropos of nothing, how excited I was because I love Chris Pratt, and I have for a long time.
这种元素体现在音乐、灯光、剪辑节奏以及所有这些方面，你真的把它玩酷了、玩潮了，它在漫威里开辟了一条完全不同的赛道。对，对，我觉得就音乐而言，我是在用这些人们不认识的角色打造一部太空歌剧，而且它完全是古怪又离奇的。所以，你要怎么用最酷的方式把这一切落地呢？我想，70年代的AM流行乐完美适合某个在，你知道的，外星墓地里跳舞的人。太酷了。我能跟你说个题外话吗，说说我当时有多兴奋，因为我太喜欢克里斯·帕特了，而且喜欢很久了。
This guy. This guy. He's a bravo. What a brother. Yeah, he's amazing. I love him. The character is a guy. He's an Italian guy.
这家伙。这家伙。他是个英雄。真是个好兄弟。对，他太棒了。我太爱他了。这个角色是个家伙。他是个意大利裔。
He's in the back of the theater, James. And I'm sorry. It's funny to only the three of us. So, and I remember when Pratt first did Parks and Rec, I remember the first season, and I was like, and he was a recurring character, and I was like, this dude is so fucking funny. Yeah.
他在剧院后面，詹姆斯。抱歉。只有我们三个觉得好笑。所以，我记得帕特刚演《公园与游憩》的时候，我记得第一季的时候，我就觉得，当时他是个常驻角色，我就觉得，这家伙太特么搞笑了。对。
I just love them. From a moment it went, so then when all of a sudden he was doing this, I remember when he got the film, the first Guardians movie, and I just thought, like, yes, the world's not going to know what to do with Chris Pratt, Because this dude is so funny, so talented. He can't even help. He's one of those guys.
我就是爱死他了。从那一刻起，所以当他突然开始演这个的时候，我记得他拿到这部电影、第一部《银河护卫队》的时候，我当时就想，太棒了，世界根本不知道该怎么应对克里斯·帕特，因为这家伙太搞笑了，太有才华了。他简直无法自控。他是那种人。
He can't help being funny. Yeah. Do you know what I mean? Oh, yeah. He's, he's, I, I text him all the time because, you know, I'm doing, you know, all sorts of, you know, press junket stuff and things like that. And I love doing press junkets with the guys I'm doing it with, with the, you know, with the Superman cast and with John Sina from Peacemaker and all that. Which I want to get into. Yeah, yeah.
他就是忍不住要搞笑。对。你知道我的意思吗？噢，对。我，我，我经常给他发短信，因为，你知道的，我正在做，你知道的，各种各样的，你知道的，媒体采访宣传活动之类的事情。我喜欢跟我一起做宣传的伙伴们一起跑宣传，和，你知道的，和《超人》剧组，还有《和平使者》里的约翰·塞纳一起。我正想聊这个。对，对。
Chris and I used to have such a great time. would you guys pair yourselves together all the time yeah yeah but it was like it just became these giggle fest where yeah yeah for sure it's so yeah I had the luxury of doing press jackets for a couple of years on the Lego stuff with Chris and it was
克里斯和我以前总是玩得太开心了。你们俩总是把自己凑成一组吗？对，对，但这就变成了一种狂笑派对，就是，对，没错，太棒了。我有幸和克里斯一起为乐高项目跑了两年的媒体宣传，那是我在演艺圈经历过的最有趣的事情之一，
some of the most fun I've ever had in showbiz who was actually doing press tours because we laughed our asses on it he'll drop the dirtiest joke like the dirtiest bomb I mean you're like wait what it makes me laugh so hard so so so good so you mentioned the peacemaker the peacemaker So you're directing all these movies
因为我们当时真的笑到肚子痛。他会抛出最荤的笑料，就像最猛的黄色炸弹。你会想：等等，什么？这让我笑得停不下来，太棒了，太棒了！所以你提到了和平使者，和平使者。所以你导演了所有这些电影，
And then you're going back for it And now you're co-chairman and CEO of D.C. studios And then you're directed the new Superman movie Which is, as we all know, directing of it Just take the years and the hours and the time and the life and blah blah And in there, you created this show The Peacemaker with John Sina Which you wrote a bunch of episodes.
然后你又回归了，现在你是DC工作室的联席董事长兼首席执行官。然后你执导了新的《超人》电影，正如我们所知，导演这部电影需要耗费岁月、时间和生命，诸如此类。而在那期间，你和约翰·塞纳一起创作了《和平使者》这部剧，你还写了很多集。
Well, I wrote, I created Peacemaker two years ago So Peacemaker, or whatever, four years ago, Peacemaker originated on HBO Max a few years ago. It was a number one show on HBO Max ever. And then I committed to a second season. And so it's my favorite cast, and I love these guys. And so I was supposed to do a second season. Then I got the job as the head of D.C. studios.
嗯，我写了，我是在两年前创作的《和平使者》，所以《和平使者》，不管怎样，四年前，《和平使者》几年前在HBO Max上首播。它是HBO Max历史上收视第一的剧集。然后我承诺要拍第二季。这是我最喜欢的演员阵容，我太爱这群人了。所以我本来应该拍第二季的。后来我得到了DC工作室主管的工作。
I was halfway through doing this animated show called Creature Commandos. And so, like, in a space of, I had to get into Superman first. So my second call after, you know, right before I got the job was announced, was to John Cena saying, I'm going to do Peacemaker, but I just have to hold a beat because I got to get Superman right. And so, yeah, in a year I wrote 650 pages of material. And then the next year I produced and directed 650 pages of material. material, and this year we're releasing 650 pages in the material.
我当时正在制作一部名为《生物突击队》的动画剧集进行到一半。所以，在一段时间内，我必须先把《超人》搞定。所以在我接到工作被宣布的前夕，我的第二个电话就是打给约翰·塞纳，告诉他：“我要拍《和平使者》，但我得稍微等一下，因为我必须先把《超人》拍好。”所以，是的，在一年里我写了650页的剧本。然后在接下来的一年里，我制作并执导了650页内容的影视作品，今年我们要把这650页的内容发布出来。
So what, tell us what your day is like? What time do you get up typically in the morning, truthfully? 10 o'clock. No, no, that's not true. But I get up pretty, I don't get up that early. So you stay up late? I stay up late, but my times fluctuate wildly. So, like, when I'm writing, I try to have as little schedule as possible
那什么，告诉我们你的一天是怎么度过的？说实话，你早上通常几点起床？10点。不，不，这不是真的。不过我起得挺早的，我其实没起那么早。所以你熬夜吗？我熬夜，但我的作息时间波动很大。所以，比如我在写作的时候，我尽量少安排日程，
because it's just the writing's in my brain all the time. So during that 650 pages, and I'm just writing out of pure panic in a lot of ways. Yeah, yeah. But then when I get to the page, it's working, you know, and then I step outside of the page and I'm terrified, step back into the page, and it's working, step outside of the page, and I'm terrified.
因为写作的想法随时都在我脑子里。所以在写那650页的期间，我在很多方面都是出于纯粹的恐慌在写。对，对，对。但当我把内容写到纸上时，它起作用了，你知道的，然后我跳出纸面审视它，我感到恐慌，再回到纸面上，它又起作用了，再跳出纸面，我又感到恐慌。
And so I just had to keep writing and writing and writing, and that was going on constantly, you know, and that was actually the busiest time was the writing of it, because, you know, when you're shooting, it's much more structured. And then I have to go into post-production and all that stuff. We'll be right back. and now back to the show you obviously love the creative process so much
所以我只能不停地写、写、写，这种状态一直在持续，你知道的，其实最忙的时候反而是写作阶段，因为，你知道的，当你开机拍摄时，结构要清晰得多。然后我就得进入后期制作之类的环节。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你显然非常热爱创作过程，
because you're so deeply involved in it and doing so much of it what was it like when you got that call to have one of the most prestigious elite jobs you could ever imagine partly running one of the biggest studios the history of the... So, like, that's an executive job.
因为你深深地投入其中，并且做了大量的工作。当你接到那个电话，去担任你能想象到的最负盛名、最精英的工作之一——部分掌管影史最大制片厂之一时，那是一种什么样的感觉？所以，这其实是一份行政管理工作。
And for the listener, like, it's wildly different to be the people that push the button that make it all happen versus the people that are on the set that actually make it. And so you're doing both. How did that land for you? It was cool.
对听众来说，按下按钮让一切成真的幕后高管，和在片场真正把电影拍出来的实干家，这两者有着天壤之别。而你两者兼顾。这对你来说意味着什么？这很酷。
I was happy. It wasn't as pure of a joy as say when I got the first Guardians movie because that was me doing something I knew how to do. Right. this was kind of creating a new job that hasn't existed
我很高兴。它不像我接到第一部《银河护卫队》时那样纯粹的快乐，因为那是我在做自己擅长的事。没错。而这有点像是在创造一个从未存在过的新职位，
because there hasn't ever been a creative in the position of studio head which is insane if you think about it right that sentence that you just uttered is quite crazy is quite crazy meaning that it hasn't happened yet because you would think you would want a creative person
因为以前从来没有一个创意人才担任过制片厂主管的职位，如果你仔细想想，这太疯狂了，对吧？你刚才说的那句话确实挺疯狂的，挺疯狂的，意思是这以前从来没有发生过，因为你会觉得，你本来就希望有一个创意人才
to be the oversight person of the creative process right right right yeah I guess yeah but also you do need to manage a lot of stuff so there's part of it and that's what i would never do the job without peter saffron yeah yeah but but but but i mean to the extent that like i and jb going off what you would just said which is i remember i remember years ago being and this is on a much much smaller scale but being in a meeting in a casting meeting for a tv show with a bunch of executives from a tv studio that does from back then this 25 years ago and and i was in i was i'd already been cast in the thing and i go in and we
来监督创意过程，对吧？对，对，对。是的，我猜是的。但你也确实需要管理很多事情，所以这其中有一部分……这就是为什么如果没有彼得·萨夫兰，我是绝对不会接这份工作的。对，对，对。但但但但我的意思是，就我和JB顺着你刚才的话说，我记得我多年前参加过一个电视节目的选角会议，虽然规模要小得多，但当时有一群来自电视制作公司的电视高管，那是25年前的事了。当时我已经通过试镜加入了那个项目，我走进去，
read a bunch of people for this other part and one of the people who runs the studio who one of the people executives after the person leaves like yeah yeah I think he's good I think he and they're having he's having this conversation he's driving the conversation about the creative of this
我们为另一个角色试镜了一群人。当其中一个人离开后，其中一个制作公司的高管——其中一个高管说：“对，对，我觉得他挺好的，我觉得他……”他们在进行这样的对话，他主导了关于这个角色的创意讨论，
casting of this actor and this guy literally was a fucking bean counter quite literally had been an accountant and he's the one making the decision on the thing that's lunacy yeah that's why most things aren't good Yeah, there used to be something called the creative committee at Marvel.
选这个演员。而这家伙字面意义上就是一个特么的精算师，以前是个会计，而他竟然在对这种事情做出决定。这太荒谬了。对，这就是为什么大多数东西都不好。对，漫威以前有个叫创意委员会的东西。
And it was, you know, comic book people and toy people and all these people that would chime in with their notes on scripts. And I think that's fine that, you know, they give notes because, you know, one of the things that you hear all these people being afraid of notes all the time, but usually you don't have to use them,
里面有漫画界的人、玩具界的人，还有所有这些人，他们会对剧本提出各种意见。我觉得他们提意见挺好的，因为，你知道的，你总是听到所有人整天都害怕听到意见，但通常你并不非得采用，
you just have to listen to them. And people are usually happy if you just listen. If you listen and then you say, I don't know because of this. They're usually okay. But they were a little bit acted as if they were, you know, the authority on everything. And so Kevin and I would, you know, we'd be working on Guardians of the Galaxy and we'd have that, you know, final screenplay. And then all of a sudden we'd get these lists of things that needed to be changed.
你只需要听取就行了。如果你只是听着，大家通常就会很高兴。如果你听了然后说：“因为这个原因，我不太确定。”他们通常也能接受。但他们有时候的表现，就好像他们是所有事情的权威一样。所以凯文和我，你知道的，我们当时在制作《银河护卫队》，我们敲定了那个最终剧本。然后突然之间，我们会收到一长串需要修改的内容清单。
And it always felt to me, like I was watching that show the Nick at the time when they used to do, you know, operational. and they'd have the audience members there. And it felt like a couple of brain surgeons performing brain surgery and having a bunch of podiatrists around telling them how to do it. And it was just like, you know, I mean, they told me to take the songs out. You know, when they saw the first cut
我当时总觉得，这就像我在看当年那个叫《尼克》的节目，他们当时在做那种运营纪实，现场有观众。那感觉就像是两个脑外科医生在做开颅手术，旁边却围了一群足病医生在告诉他们该怎么做。这感觉就像是，你知道的，他们竟然让我把音乐删掉。你知道的，当他们看到第一版剪辑时，
and Bradley was doing Rocket's voice as a character, they were like, why do we pay all this money without, you know, he doesn't sound like Bradley Cooper. I'm like, yeah, he's playing a character. He's an actor. That's what the guy does. That's why we hired him. And it was just a list of, you know, things that they just had nothing to do with storytelling,
布莱德利给火箭浣熊配音，他们就说：“我们花了这么多钱，他听起来怎么一点都不像布莱德利·库珀？”我说：“对啊，他在演一个角色。他是个演员。这就是演员做的事。这就是我们雇他的原因。”那只是一长串，你知道的，跟讲故事毫无关系的东西，
nothing to do with what would capture people's imaginations. Right. And just whatever their peculiarities were. So you thought with this opportunity maybe would come not a sea change in what the executive ranks would look like, but at least you would be able to influence this studio in a direction that made a little bit more sense? I thought it gave me an opportunity. First of all, I thought it was cool because D.C. was breaking off from Warner Brothers and becoming its own studio, which was awesome. That had never been done.
跟捕捉人们想象力毫无关系的东西。纯粹是他们自己的怪癖罢了。所以你以为这个机会带来的，也许不是高管阶层面貌的彻底颠覆，但至少你能把这家制片厂引导向一个更有意义的方向？我觉得这给了我一个机会。首先，我觉得这很酷，因为DC要从华纳兄弟独立出来，成为自己的制片厂，这太棒了。以前从来没有人这么做过。
You know, Marvel is still under Disney. And then secondly, I thought it was an opportunity to try something that had never been done before, which was to create a cohesive universe, but also a cohesive brand that was about quality. And I only am going to be on this earth for so long. So, why does, you know, might as well put everything into it. an opportunity that just has never existed for anyone ever. So how could I say no to that, my wife, which is I had? But, you know, how could I say no to that? But that presupposes that you're able to have a certain amount of authority and influence.
你知道，漫威仍然隶属于迪士尼。其次，我觉得这是一个尝试前所未有之举的机会，那就是打造一个凝聚力强的宇宙，同时也是一个以品质为核心的凝聚力品牌。我在这个世上活不了那么久，所以，既然如此，为什么不把全部心血都投入进去呢？这是一个前人从未有过的机会。我怎么能对它说不呢？对我妻子说不？虽然我确实说过。但是，你知道，我怎么能对这个机会说不呢？但这前提是你得拥有一定程度的权威和影响力。
What kind of, to the extent you're comfortable sharing, were you given assurances that made you think, well, there's a possibility I could actually do this? Oh, I knew that we could. Yeah, yeah, because the only person we answered to, is David Zazlov. And David Zazlov has, he tells it if he likes something or he doesn't like something,
在你能透露的范围内，你得到了什么样的保证，让你觉得“好吧，我其实有可能做到这一点”？哦，我知道我们可以。对，对，因为我们唯一需要对负责的人，就是大卫·扎斯拉夫。大卫·扎斯拉夫会直言不讳地表达他喜欢什么或不喜欢什么，
but he doesn't have any sort of say or interest in saying, it's not that he doesn't have any say if he wanted to, I guess he could, but he doesn't have any interest in saying the story A and story, he's the opposite of the guy. Will was talking about that.
但他没有任何指手画脚的意愿或兴趣去说——倒不是说如果他想的话他不能指手画脚，我想他或许可以，但他根本没有兴趣去说“故事A和故事B该怎么走”，他跟威利刚才说的那种人完全相反。
Yeah, he's very deferential to the creatives. Yeah. He loves David. Zaz gets it. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, so he's not, you know, he doesn't think that he knows how to do that, you know? Right.
对，他对创作者非常尊重。对。他很喜欢大卫。扎斯懂行。对，对。所以他不是那种，你知道的，他不会觉得自己懂得怎么去搞创作，你知道吗？对。
One of the most terrifying calls ever was, you know, I had done the screen test with David Corencewit and Rachel Brazman. And, you know, and they were so freaking good together. And I loved them. And Peter loved them. And Chantal, our executive producer, loved them. And I sent the tape off to Dave, and I said, here's our two choices. Yeah.
最让人心惊肉跳的电话之一就是，你知道的，我当时和大卫·科伦斯韦以及瑞秋·布罗斯纳安做了银幕试镜。而且，你知道的，他们俩在一起的化学反应太棒了。我爱死他们了。彼得也爱他们。我们的执行制片人尚塔尔也爱他们。我把磁带发给了大卫，我说：“这就是我们的两个选择。对。
Here's what we want to do. And David called me up, and he goes, and he sounds really dower. And he goes, you know, I have to preface this by saying, this isn't what I do, this isn't what I know, you know, I'm not a movie business guy, you know, movie creator. I'm not a storyteller like you are. This is just coming from a place of me as a person. And then he stopped and he goes, I fucking love it.
这就是我们想做的人选。”大卫打电话给我，他说起话来语气听起来很沮丧，他说：“你知道，我得先声明一下，这不是我干的活，这不是我懂的领域，你知道的，我不是电影业的人，不是电影创作者。我不是像你那样会讲故事的人。这纯粹是我作为一个普通人的直觉。”然后他停顿了一下，说：“我特么太喜欢了。”
That's so good. I like you are an asshole. What a cool dude. What a cool dude So then James now Just to kind of switch gears a little bit So you're doing all this stuff And of course we're all kind of
太棒了。我觉得你真是个混蛋。真是个酷毙的家伙。真是个酷毙的家伙！所以，詹姆斯，现在，为了稍微转换一下话题——所以你在做所有这些事情，当然了，我们大家其实都
All of our ships Are pointed into the headwind of AI And what kind of effect it's going to have on the future of film And stuff And we've kind of been asking everybody a little bit You guys must be at the sort of the tip of the spear When it comes to filmmaking
乘风破浪，迎着人工智能的逆风前行，它将对电影的未来等产生什么样的影响。我们一直在问每个人这些问题。你们一定正处于电影制作的最前沿，
And where it intersects with AI and how we can use it and what we need to look out for and what you think the future might hold for films. I hated when we were going through all the guild dispute stuff and AI was the big part of it because we're just not quite there at that point yet with writing and acting.
无论是它与人工智能的交汇点，还是我们如何使用它，我们需要防范什么，以及你们认为电影的未来会怎样。当我们在经历工会纠纷的时候，我很讨厌AI成为其中的核心部分，因为我们在剧本创作和表演方面其实还没发展到那个阶段。
And so there were all these important issues that we needed to talk about. And it's like AI, the splashy thing is making all the headlines, all my friends online are getting upset about AI stuff. And I'm like, guys, really, look at what's happening. This isn't a real thing in this moment.
所以当时有很多我们需要讨论的重要议题。而AI呢，最哗众取宠的噱头占据了所有头条，我网上所有的朋友都在为AI的事情感到心烦意乱。我说：“伙计们，说真的，看看现实发生了什么吧。这在当下并不是一个真实存在的威胁。”
You know, I have a stunt-y friend who's like, they're going to use my body and they have the rights to my body. I'm like, they don't want your body. They want the body of the guy, the actor that you play. Right. But I do, I think it's in the moment, it's a problem for the low-level jobs, which is where I feel the most compassion by, say,
你知道，我有个做特技的朋友说：“他们要用我的身体，他们拥有我身体的版权。”我说：“他们才不想要你的身体。他们想要的是你替身的那位演员的身体。”不过说真的，我认为它在当下确实对底层工作构成了威胁，这是我最同情的地方，比如
with VFX all the people that do all the rotoscoping and all these sort of more tedious jobs that is going to be replaced by AI in the next couple of years almost certainly and I don't think there's anything we can
视觉特效领域，所有做抠像（rotoscoping）和这些比较繁琐的工作人员，在接下来的几年里，几乎可以肯定会被AI取代。而且我认为我们对此
do about that I don't think there's any way that a studio is going to say yeah let's spend an extra $40 million on this movie yeah yeah I mean I think just setting aside the actual replacement of jobs
无能为力。我不认为会有哪个制片厂会说：“好吧，让我们在这部电影上多花4000万美元吧。”对，对。我是说，抛开实际的岗位被取代和人员失业等问题不谈，最终的成品在我们的案例中是完全不同的。而且每一部都是独一无二的。每一种娱乐形式最终都将取决于你实际消费的内容，也就是你想消费的原创娱乐。贾比尔，这有可能由人工智能来创造。我觉得这是我的问题所在。
and people, et cetera. And the actual end product is different in this, in our case. And each one is unique. Each sort of, you know, entertainment is going to be what you actually consume, which is what you want to consume original entertainment. That has the potential to be created by AI, J.B. I think that's my sort of question.
是的，但我的意思是，它现在还差得很远。所以，你还得做很多事情。我是说，你知道的，你现在看到的只是8秒钟的剪辑片段，即便如此，如果你坐进一辆出租车里，下一秒你突然就坐到了出租车的前排座位上，对吧？对，对，对。所以，你得明白，AI背后还是需要艺术性和工作的。
Yeah, but I mean, it's so, it is a little bit of ways right now. So it's, you've got to do a lot of stuff. I mean, it's, you know, the things that you're watching are eight-second clips of things, and even then if you put, you know, get into a cab, you're suddenly getting into the front seat of the cab, you know? Right, right, right. So it's, you got to, it's, there is artistry and work behind AI.
我玩过很多次。玩起来挺有意思的。所以我其实并不清楚。我可不是特么的算命先生，但我非常清楚当下的问题所在。等等。我以为我们很有兴趣呢。我以为你是个特么的算命先生。另一个，但另一个问题，对我来说是个更大的问题，
I've played with it a lot. It's fun to play with. And so I don't really know. I'm not the fucking fortune teller, but I do, I am very aware of what the present problem. Wait a second. I thought we were interested. I thought you were a fucking fortune teller. The other, but the other problem, for me, kind of the bigger problem,
特别是在视觉特效行业里，所有那些将要保留下来的工作岗位人员——你知道，很多动画师其实就像是技术演员，因为他们在创造这些角色的动作以及他们的移动方式。而培养这些岗位的训练场现在没了。那么你该如何学习成为那样的人呢？下一代人才该如何涌现？我认为这在每个行业都大同小异。所以双重问题是，在这样一个本就工作岗位不足的世界里，这些拥有其他工作的人究竟该去哪里？
especially in the VFX industry, is that all the people that do the jobs that are going to remain, you know, a lot of the animators are actually like almost like technical actors because they're creating the actions of these characters, the way they move. And the people, the training ground for those jobs is gone now. So how do you learn how to be those people? How does the next generation of people come about? And I think that's pretty much going to be true in every industry. So the double problem is, where do all these people go that have these other jobs in a world that's already doesn't have enough jobs?
然后人们又该如何通过培训提升到下一个层级呢？这难道不意味着我们很快就会在最高层级涌现出更多训练不足的人吗？不过，我觉得可能会有一大批观众根本不在乎——抱歉，说到编剧，将来会有优秀的编剧，也会有一大批观众其实并不那么在乎起承转合，只要故事有头有尾就行，
And then how do the people train to get to the next level? Doesn't that mean that we're instantly going to have more ill-trained people at the top next level? Yeah, I do think, though, that there's probably going to be a big audience that doesn't care about, I'm sorry, talking about writers, there's going to be great writers, and there's going to be a huge part of the audience that doesn't care about the beginning, middle, and end so much just as long as there is one,
不管它有多烂，只要有汽车追逐和爆炸戏，他们就会买单，哪怕整部电影完全是由AI生成的。天哪，我真希望斯科蒂现在能从背景里走过去。我想这可能是真的。不过，我不知道。我是说，这取决于它发展到什么程度，你知道的，因为记住，AI是在吞噬它自己的审美品味。
it doesn't matter how good it is, as long as there's car chases and explosions, they'll show up, even if the whole thing is totally AI. God, I wish Scottie would walk by in the background right now. I think maybe that's true. I mean, I don't know, though. I mean, it depends on how developed it gets, you know, because remember, AI is eating its own taste.
没错。它不是在汲取新养分，它无法创造出新东西。它实际上只是在进行各种大杂烩式的拼凑。但我的意思是，我们必须喂养它。是的，但我说的是，确实存在这样一部分观众。他们根本不在乎。在接下来的几年里，我不认为情况会是这样。我认为你从那里面得到的东西，就是一部霍尔马克频道（Hallmark）的爱情肥皂剧。
That's right. It's not feeding, it can't create something new. It's really just creating amalgamations. But I'm saying, we have to feed it. Yes, but I'm saying there's an audience for that. They don't care. Where it will be in the next few years, I don't think that's true. I think that what you get out of that is you get a hallmark movie.
对，好吧，这就是我的意思。确实有观众喜欢看霍尔马克电影。哦，对，对。确实有观众喜欢看霍尔马克电影，但你没法靠一部霍尔马克电影在票房上赚到十亿美元。而且无论如何你都不能承担不起拍电影的后果。希望流程中那个被自动化取代的入门级环节能带来一些好处，
Yeah, well, that's what I'm saying. There's an audience for Hallmark movies. Oh, yeah, yeah. There's an audience for Hallmark movies, but you can't make a billion dollars at the box office with the Hallmark movie. And you can't really afford to make movies no matter what. Hopefully there's a benefit from that entry-level part of the process that may become automated. Hopefully that will potentially save enough money for the industry, that it'll then be reinvested into the industry and help the financial health of the industry
希望这能为行业节省足够的资金，然后将这些资金重新投资到行业中，帮助行业的财务健康状况重振旗鼓。因为现在我们的行业正在经历某种紧缩，对吧？缺乏工作机会，缺乏产品。制片厂拍的电影越来越少，因为发行和制作成本越来越高。希望这能让行业恢复财务健康，然后让所有人重新回到工作岗位上，也许是从事其他工作，也许会有更多作品被制作出来。我是说，也许这有点过于乐观了，但希望它能……我不认为，我是说，我觉得你的核心观点是，
get stood up again. because right now there's a bit of a constraint going on in our industry, right? There's a lack of work, there's a lack of product. Studios are making less films because it's becoming more and more expensive to sell them and make them. Hopefully this will allow that financial help to come back to the industry and then put all these people back to work again, maybe in some other job, but maybe there'll be more product being made. I mean, maybe that's Pollyanna, but hopefully it will... I don't think, I mean, I think that your basic point is,
绝对正确的。我是说，你可以用更低的成本拍出更有大片质感的电影。我是说，像《超人》这样的电影，你知道，差不多有一半的预算都花在视觉特效上了。对，没错。那可是个大预算电影。它虽然没有《银河护卫队3》或者其他那些大片那么贵，但其中很大一部分成本花在演员身上了。我觉得，我觉得，贾比尔，我觉得你是对的。要么这是真的，要么就是截然相反，
absolutely true. I mean, that you can make bigger-feeling movies cheaper. I mean, a movie like Superman is, you know, nearly half of its budget is in VFX. Yeah, right. That's a lot. It's a big
我们死定了，一切都在烈火中崩塌。看看汽车行业。我不知道具体数字，但我觉得那是一个健康的行业。音乐行业，经历了所有这一切，经历了那种巨大的数字变革，我认为那也是一个健康的行业。我觉得音乐行业其实被坑得很惨。它们挺好玩的。对，它们被坑惨了，因为，是的，音乐行业当时完全没有意识到流媒体变革即将来临。
budget film. It's not as big as you know, you know, Guardians 3 or, you know, these other things, but a lot of that's the actors, you know. I think, I think, J.B., I think you're right. It's either, either that is true or the opposite. And we're doomed and it's all crashing into a fire.
他们被剥夺了一切。所以词曲作者被剥夺了一切，你知道的。你知道的，我业余时间做的一件事就是写歌。而且，你知道的，我有播放量达到4000万次的歌曲，你知道的，在Spotify上有4000万次播放。我从来没注意到有哪一美元是从那上面进账的。
Look at the automotive industry. I don't know the numbers, but I feel like it's a healthy industry. The music industry, with all of that, that big digital change that happened, that I think that's a healthy industry. I think the music industry got kind of screwed. They're fun. Yeah, they got screwed because, yeah, the music industry had no awareness. This streaming change was coming.
我可能也就赚了几千美元。但那也只是几千美元。哇。那可是首超级热门歌曲。对。所以这就好比，你知道的，人们，你知道的，现在人们赚钱主要靠巡演，很高兴现场音乐行业依然在蓬勃发展。
And they just, they got screwed out of everything. So the writers, songwriters got screwed out of everything, you know. You know, so like one of the things I do in my spare time is I've written songs. And, you know, I have songs that have like 40. Spare time. How do you have? 40 million hits of, you know, 40 million plays on Spotify. I don't, I've never noticed a dollar coming in from that.
但就音乐人像以前那样靠专辑销量和歌曲赚钱而言，已经不复存在了。我本来想说的是，巡演的存在——对我而言——表明人们依然渴望真正的的人际连接。我认为这将是抵制这种趋势的力量，也将是最抢手的商品。
And I'm probably have made a few thousand dollars. But that's a few thousand dollars. Wow. That's a huge song. Yeah. And so it's like, you know, people, you know, people make money from today from today from touring, which is great that the live music industry is thriving.
没错，而且我跟——顺便说一句，我周末家里来了一群十几岁的青少年，我儿子们的朋都过来了，我问了所有这些家伙，我说：“你们觉得长大后想做什么？”我们进行了长时间的讨论。其中一个人说：“哦，我想从事体育行业，我想做数据分析、数字之类的工作。”我说：“那个没戏了。”
But in terms of musicians making money, like how they used to, from album sales and songs, you know, it's not there. Well, I was going to say that the touring is, and here, for me, that is an indicator that what people still crave is the human connection. And I think that that is going to be a thing that pushes back against things like that's going to be the biggest commodity.
我会选一些新的方向，因为所有这些将来都会被AI处理掉。我是认真的。如果你指的是一个将不复存在的职业。但我确实认为，唯一不会消失的，将是对真实人际连接的渴望，这种渴望将成为一种变得更加稀缺的商品，
Right, and I talked to, by the way, I had all these teenagers, my sons had their friends over all weekend, and I was asking all these guys, I was like, what do you guys think you're going to do when you grow up, and we're having these long conversations? And one of them said, oh, I want to get into sports, and I want to get into analytics, into numbers and stuff, and go, that's gone.
人们愿意为获得真实的体验支付高价——无论是面对面的、现场的，还是任何形式的真实体验。这就是核心价值。所以你会出场为某人跳舞咯，对吧？只要出价合适的话。我要去做类似OnlyFans那种平台，不过是提供线下OnlyFans私人舞蹈服务。
I would pick something new because all that will be crunched by AI. I'm serious. Like, if you talk about a vocation that's not going to exist. But I do think, I do think the one thing is, is going to be the desire for. for real human connection, that is going to be a commodity that is going to become even more exclusive
哇，那可真是……对啊，为了钱跳私人舞蹈，任何老掉牙的音乐都行。穿着超人的紧身短裤。你会去跳的。我们落魄了啊。我确实认为，电影、电视剧或者小说，它们全都是艺术表达，也全都是一种沟通形式。
and people will pay a premium to have a real experience, a one-on-one, a live, whatever that is, experience. And that's the good. So you'll show up, you'll dance for someone, right? If you get sent the right dollar amount. I'm going to do like only fans, but an in-person only-fans private dance.
它们全都是一个人或一群人与其他人沟通的形式。我认为，如果人们觉得这种沟通层面消失了，这对很多人来说将是一个减分项，因为当你去看电影或看电视剧时，那种情感共鸣是真实存在的。但你觉得会不会出现这样一种电影赛道——它跟动画有点像，对吧？动画是我们娱乐产业里巨大的一块，你知道的，迪士尼动画、皮克斯之类的。
Wow, that's... Yeah, private dance from dancing for money, any old musical will do. In Superman's trunks. You'll do it. We've fallen on bad times. I do think that a film or a television show or something that's a novel, they're all artistic expressions and they're all a form of communication.
那些可不是真人。那是画出来的虚拟角色。所以，也许会存在一个与真人电影并存的AI电影赛道，
They're all a form of one, you know, either person or a group of people communicating to other people. And I think that if people feel that communication aspect is not there, that's going to be a drawback for a lot of people because there is that feeling. when you're seeing a movie or watching a TV show. But do you think that there'll be a lane of films not too dissimilar from animation, right? It's a huge section of our entertainment industry, you know, Disney animation and Pixar and the like.
它们都是一种形式，你知道的，无论是个人还是一群人在与其他人交流。我认为，如果人们觉得缺少了那种交流的层面，这对很多人来说会是一个缺点，因为会有那种感觉，当你正在看电影或看电视节目时。但是你认为会有一类电影，与动画不太一样，对吧？这是我们娱乐产业中很大的一部分，你知道的，迪士尼动画、皮克斯以及类似的。
Those don't have real. What kind of films, J.B., like, are there new ones coming out of the next thing? Oh, here, yeah. But, like, you know, those aren't actors. Those are drawn figures. And so there's, it will be a lane, perhaps, of AI films that live next to,
那些没有真人。什么样的电影，J.B.，比如说，接下来的新作品里有吗？哦，这里，是的。但是，你知道，那些不是演员。那些是绘制的人物。所以可能，会有一类AI电影，与它们并存，
animated films that live next to live action films that maybe they'll be a different price point maybe I don't know maybe but I think it's also what are you talking about as AI films are you meaning 100% generated by AI from start to finish I don't know but like whatever animation is I mean you have real actors that are that are giving voice the voice actors behind it so there'll be a combination I bet it's going to affect animation almost certainly you know I mean you know it it definitely will yeah so you're in a band you still play no I'm not a band now. I don't play. I just, you know, I thought you were. I mean, I wasn't a band. That's how I, like...
动画电影将会与真人电影并存，也许它们会有不同的定价，也许吧，我不知道，也许会。但我也觉得，你在谈论AI电影时指的是什么？你是说从头到尾百分之百由AI生成吗？我不知道，不过不管动画是什么，我是说，有真正的演员在为它配音，幕后有配音演员，所以这会是一个结合体。我敢打赌，它几乎肯定会影响动画，你知道的，绝对会的。所以你以前在一个乐队里，你现在还玩音乐吗？不，我现在不在乐队了。我不玩了。我只是，你知道，我以为你是。我是说，我以前在一个乐队里。那就是我如何，就像...
Oh, I didn't know if you still played, yeah. No, I still play. I still play some piano, but I still write music with, um, in various times. You know, like, uh, Red Miller and I wrote songs together for the Guardians of the Galaxy Christmas special. Yeah, right. And I wrote a song with Tyler Bates for Guardians too. I wrote stuff for Scooby-Doo. What about scoring a film? For me, I could never do... I'm not that... I'm not punk rock kid. What if you sit? What if you say? Yeah, I mean, Well, if Johnny Greenwood can do it, you can do it.
哦，我不知道你是不是还在玩音乐，是的。不，我还在玩。我还会弹一些钢琴，但我有时仍会与人一起写歌，在不同的时期。你知道，比如，雷德·米勒和我一起为《银河护卫队》圣诞特别篇写过歌。对，没错。我还和泰勒·贝茨一起为《银河护卫队2》写过一首歌。我为《史酷比》写过东西。为电影配乐怎么样？对我来说，我永远做不到...我不是那种...我不是朋克摇滚小子。如果你坐下来呢？如果你说呢？对，我是说，如果强尼·格林伍德能做到，你也能做到。
Yeah, okay. No, I couldn't. I couldn't do it. All right. Listen, James Gunn, we could talk to you, honestly. We say this sometimes, but we could just keep going. But we've taken up way too much. We're already over.
好吧，不，我做不到。我真的做不到。好了，听着，詹姆斯·冈恩，说实话我们可以一直跟你聊下去。我们有时会这么说，但我们可以一直聊下去。不过我们已经占用了太多时间了。我们已经超时了。
Oh, my goodness. It's so fascinating. We're so excited. The peacemaker comes out this summer, right? That peacemaker is live on August 21st on HBO Max. and there is a podcast inspired by Smartless solely with me and Jennifer Holland, who plays Harcourt, who also happens to be my wife,
哦，天哪。太迷人了。我们太兴奋了。和平使者今年夏天上映，对吧？《和平使者》将于8月21日在HBO Max上直播，还有一个受《聪明糊涂心》启发而制作的播客，只有我和詹妮弗·霍兰德——她饰演哈奎特，恰好也是我的妻子——
and Steve Agee, who plays Economos, and then many guest stars from Daniel Brooks to John Cena and so forth. And that takes place twice a week up until the release that we go over every single episode of Peacemaker. That's great. That's fun. That's cool. All right, so that's available now.
以及饰演埃科莫斯的史蒂夫·阿吉，还有许多特邀嘉宾，从丹尼尔·布鲁克斯到约翰·塞纳等等。这个播客每周更新两次，一直持续到发布，我们会回顾《和平使者》的每一集。那太棒了。真有趣。太酷了。好的，所以现在就可以收听了。
The podcast is available in our first. What's the podcast called? I believe it's called Peacemaker, the official podcast with James Gunn. It's a wonderful. And how did you guys come up with that? I don't know. A creative committee of sorts came up with it by AI. Please tell, please tell Sean to her.
这个播客现在可以收听了。这个播客叫什么名字？我想它叫《和平使者：詹姆斯·冈恩官方播客》。真是太棒了。你们是怎么想出这个名字的？我不知道。某种创意委员会通过AI想出来的。请告诉，请代我向肖恩问好。
It was so nice meeting her when I saw her. Oh, I will. Absolutely, Sean. Yeah, she loved you and Scott. Same to Scott, by the way. I will, yeah. Well, fantastic. Well, continued success.
见到她真是太好了。哦，我一定会的，绝对的，肖恩。对，她很喜欢你和斯科特。顺便代我向斯科特问好。我会的，嗯。太棒了。祝你事事顺利。
We're so happy that we have a creative like you at the helm of at least one of the studios and uh you're just doing an awesome job and we're all i'm such a fan i'm to say i know we all are and it's just been such a joy to have you like pleasure to meet you say hi to peter too i will thanks guys nice me and you jason take care guys pleasure you too pal thank you james bye buddy bye very nice how cool that's pretty cool yeah we had uh mike deluca and pam abdi on a while ago over there at Warner Brothers as well, that's pretty cool. Yeah, that's awesome. I love talking about the, like,
我们很高兴能有像你这样富有创意的人掌管至少一个工作室，而且你做得太棒了，我们都是——我是说我知道我们所有人都是你的粉丝，能有你加入真是太高兴了，很高兴认识你。也代我向彼得问好。我会的，谢谢你们，很高兴认识你们，杰森。保重，伙计们，很高兴，你也是，老兄。谢谢你，詹姆斯。再见，伙计。再见。非常好。多酷啊，真是太酷了。对，我们前不久也请了迈克·德卢卡和帕姆·阿比去华纳兄弟做过客，那真的很酷。对，太棒了。我喜欢聊这种，呃，
the different opinions of people in our business where they think it's gonna go because of AI. Everybody has a different kind of take or angle. These guys have their hand on the lever too. Yeah, yeah. They'll tell you exactly where it's going. My favorite quote from today's episode is Jason going, I don't know for sure, but I feel like the auto industry is doing well.
我们在这一行里的人对于它因为AI将会走向何方的不同看法。每个人都有不同的观点或角度。这些家伙也掌握着方向盘呢。对，对。他们会告诉你它究竟会走向何方。今天这一集里我最喜欢的一句话是杰森说：“我不是百分之百确定，但我感觉汽车工业现在发展得挺好。”
Is it? I mean. speculation I haven't worked and I said that about music too and he's like yeah no I was not good I was like okay sorry
是吗？我是说。这纯属猜测，我没有工作过。而且我对音乐也这么说过，然后他就像是，不，我当时不在状态。我当时就想，好吧，抱歉。
what do I know I feel like it's I feel like it's doing okay I see a bunch of cars on the road James I'm hearing I can't stop noticing car I was in a car today
我懂什么呀。我只是觉得它，我感觉它发展得还可以，我在路上看到了很多汽车，詹姆斯。我听到，我忍不住注意到汽车，我今天还坐了一辆车呢。
you don't want to come to us for what's going on no no he was great though I love his stuff. I didn't know Supergirl was a thing. I didn't know that. He's got that coming out after Superman.
你可别来找我们咨询时事。不，不，不过他真的很棒。我喜欢他的作品。我以前不知道还有《超女》这回事。我不知道。他将在《超人》之后推出那部作品。
I'll watch both of those. Don't you think it should be Superwoman, though? Anyway. Oh, yeah, instead of Superboy. If I can get online and start fighting with people. Yeah, but it should be. But Willie, so I'm going to see you tonight for dinner for sure. Yeah.
这两部我都会看。你不觉得应该叫《超女（Superwoman）》吗？不管怎样。哦，对，而不是超级男孩。如果我可以上网开始跟别人吵架的话。对，但确实应该叫那个。不过威利，那我今晚肯定会去跟你一起吃晚饭。对。
All right, so I'm going to see you there for a quick bye. Bye, tonight. That's not where I was going, but sure, that's good. By 7 o'clock. That's what it was. Smartless. Smart. Smart.
好吧，那我会在那儿跟你作个短暂的告别。今晚见。我刚才不是那个意思，不过当然，那样也挺好。7点之前。就是这样。《聪明糊涂心》。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。本·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫100%有机且手工打造了《聪明糊涂心》。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。